[Zene]
Szervusz, Edit! Üdvözöllek! Hogy vagy ma
reggel? Köszönöm szépen, én is
üdvözöllek. Jól vagyok, izgalommal
készültem az itt létre a találkozással.
Na de bizakodó is a szívem egyben, hogy
tudjuk folytatni azt, amit elkezdtünk a
múltkor. A az igazságra, hogy bennem is
van izgalom, tehát hogy egy ilyen furcsa
nem várt izgalom jött fel most bennem ma
reggel. Ö tegnap még nem volt bennem, de
ugye ahogy most közeledett, úgy érzem,
hogy tényleg valami ö kemény beszélgetés
lesz megint. És az igazság kemény volt
az elmúlt, tehát a a a 14. epizódunk,
ami ugyancsak a nárcizmusról szólt, ez
ez egy kemény epizód volt. Te hogy
érezted magad a forgatás alatt?
Nehéz volt megélnem. Tehát akkora
súllyal jött rám, mint amekkora súlya
van ennek az egész témának, meg ennek a
működésének, meg a ahogy megélhetik,
feltételezem, azok, akik átéltek
bántalmazásokat. Tehát mindenképp egy
teher volt rajtam végig a felvétel alatt
is, úgy előtte is, meg utána is, meg
ahogy így szemléltem a visszajelzéseket,
a kommenteket
akár terhe volt. Azt hiszem, hogy nem
tudom te hogy vagy vele, de én nekem az
volt az érzésem, hogy picit
felkészületlenül ért engem ez a ez a
teher. Tehát én én beleástam magam ebbe
a témába, és úgy éreztem, hogy
magabiztosan mozgok így a nárcizmus
témán belül, de amikor elkezdtünk
beszélgetni, úgy éreztem, hogy megy fel
a cukrom, egyre egyre idegesebb vagyok,
egyre feszültebb, úgy éreztem, hogy hogy
valamit tényleg úgy mintogyha
összenyomná a gyomrom, és és
felkészületlen voltam. Most igyekeztem
viszont készülni így érzelmi
szempontból, hogy hogy küldetésünk van,
tovább kell beszéljük ezt a témát.
És és annál is inkább, hogy képzeld,
hogy hogy az összes kommentet amúgy
elolvastam, de a mai reggel AI-jal
összegeztem, hogy kábé mit gondoltak az
emberek az elmúlt időszakban. Nagyon
nagyon sok komment érkezett és nagyon
sok visszajelzést kaptunk, több
kategóriára lehet osztani. Az egyik az,
hogy rengeteg szenvedés van. Rengeteg
szenvedés van a nárcizmus miatt. Tehát,
hogy egyik legnézettebb, nem a
legnézettebb epizódunk ez az epizód.
Sőt, aránytalanul nézettebb. Ezt az
epizódot annyit annyian nézték, mint az
összes többit. Tehát itt a Paretto
eloszlás itt is érvényes a a csatornámon
belül, de rengeteg szenvedés van emiatt.
Rengeteg. A másik észrevétel így a
kommentek alapján, hogy a kommentelők
85%-a nő, akik kommenteltek. És tudod,
ez egy dinemma volt bennem, hogy
statisztikailag azt láttam, és Ramani is
erről beszél, hogy a túlnyomó
többségben, tehát ilyen 80%-ban nők az
áldozatok és 20%-ban
férfiak. Pontosabban 80%-ban férfiak a
nárcisztikusok és 20%-ban
ők, de most mintogyha ezt visszaadná ez
a komment is, tehát ez a több mint 400
kommentet kaptunk. Ö pontosabban nem
kevesebb mint 400-at 800 bocsánat 5 385
komment érkezett be a mai napig és ennek
85%-a nő. Neked amúgy mi a tapasztalatod
ezzel kapcsolatban, vagy a praxisod
során? Hát különböző kulcszavak jutnak
eszembe, amit érzékelek, hogy a
férfiaknál ott van az erődemonstráció.
Tehát aki nárcisztikus aspektusokkal
bír, mert ugye megegyeztük, hogy az
aspektusokról fogunk beszélni, mert hogy
az a téma, ami úgy rálátással bír
részemről, meg szakmailag is inkább ez.
És amit érzékelek, ugye, tehát az
erődemonstráció azok felé megy ki, akik
kiszolgáltatottabbak meg erőtlenebbek.
Nekem az a tapasztalatom például, hogy a
nők sokkal inkább kérnek segítséget,
tehát sokkal több nőt látok én is
megfordulni a segítségkérést illetően.
És amit érzékelek, tehát valahogy a
férfiak, hogyha érintettek ők a
bántalmazott fél, az mintha tényleg
látensebb módon lenne jelen, és nem úgy
indulnak el segítséget kérni. Tehát egy
picit mintha cikibb lenne egy férfinak
bevállalni azt, hogy ő otthon
bántalmazott, de hogy van ilyen is
persze. És a kommentek alapján is ugye
ez ki volt emelve, hogy férfiak is
vannak bántalmazott pozícióban.
Abszolút. Sőt, az egyik férfi kommentelő
ezt hozta fel pontosan érvnek, hogy bár
tényleg statisztikailag a nők látszanak
jobban, ugyanannyi férfi is áldozat
valójában, és csak ők nem mernek
elszólalni valószínűleg. Úgyhogy bennem
van a gyanú, nagyon nehéz eldöntenem,
hogy mi is így a helyzet, mert a
személyes tapasztalatom is ez, hogy
azért főként főként férfiakat ismerek,
akik ennyire grandiózus
vagy rejtett nárcisztikusok.
Igen, hát lehet, hogy ezt nem fogjuk
tudni eldönteni. Amúgy utánaan néztem és
és néztem kutatásokat is, de nagyon
nehéz ezeket
számszerűsíteni. Igen. A a másik
kategóriájú visszajelzés, amit kaptunk,
az az, hogy nagyon tetszett az
embereknek, hogy keresztény szempontból
közelítettük meg, tehát a Biblia
szempontjából közelítettük meg ezt a
témát, ami bizonyos szempontból
hiánycikk is, úgymond kevés ilyen ehhez
hasonló tartalom van.
Igazából ez nem volt tervünk, tehát hogy
mondjam úgy a mellékterméke annak, hogy
hogy te is és én is egy hívő háttérből
egy spirituális alapozással jövünk. De
hogy ez nagyon fontos volt az emberek
számára. Ugyanakkor viszont
megemlítették sokan vagy többen, tehát
egyrészt negatívan ér, tehát túlnyomó
többségben pozitív volt az emberek
számára, hogy egy keresztény motívumot
is behoztunk. volt néhány kommentelő
viszont, aki ezt nehezen fogadta el.
Tehát látszott, hogy hogy igazán meg
vannak bántva az egyház által. És
felismerül bennem ez a kérdés, hogy van
egy pár olyan kérdéskör, amivel én sem
nagyon tudok mit kezdeni őszintén
szólva. Ugye a az egyházi körökben
bevallom, hogy nem tudok, tehát
gondoltam, hogy most felhozom témának,
hogy boncolgassuk, de igazi válaszaim
nincsenek. Például ha valaki egy toxikus
kapcsolatban él otthon, akár egy
bántalmazó kapcsolatban, és menekülni
akar, az egyházban a válás az nem egy
elfogadott dolog, sőt, tehát egy egy
olyan valami, ami ami mondjam úgy
büntetve van, vagy vagy a következményei
vannak, de láttam viszont olyan
kapcsolatot így a környezetemben, ahol
tényleg egy felszabadulást hozott egy
válás. És nehéz eldöntenem akkor, hogy
most pontosan mi is a mélyebb
bölcsesség. Nem tudom, ezzel
kapcsolatban van-e valamilyen
gondolatod? Én is örülök annak, hogy
behoztuk a keresztény szemlélet módon
keresztüli megközelítést, vagy a
keresztény szemléletmódot. Úgymond én
amikor Kolozsváron voltam 20 évvel
ezelőtt emlékszem, akkor még a
pszichológia
biopszichoszociális lényként definiálta
az embert. Aztán rá egy-két évre már a
biopszichoszociális és a spirituális
rész is megjelent, ami nekem így nagy
örömömre szolgált, mert ez mind
megyazott annak, hogy a pasztorál
pszichológiai területek, amin mozgok,
ugye ott még inkább megerősítve éreztem
magam ebben, és nem tudom nem ott hagyni
ezt a részt, tehát nem tudok ezzel nem
foglalkozni, mert ugye a remény az, ami
odaköti az embert valahogy a változáshoz
vagy ahhoz az áthíveléshez, ami neki
nehézség. a felüléveléshez, a
felemelkedéshez, amit érzékelek, én
inkább azon a vonalon mennék, hogyha te
is benne vagy, hogy a bibliai
emberképnek a fogalma, amikor érinteném
ezt a részt, hogy a spirituális részt,
nem
szedném külön, hogy hogyan gondolkodnak
úgy általában, hanem inkább, hogy Jézus
hogyan bánt az emberrel. át a bibliai
emberkép, hogy hogyan állt ki az
emberért, vagy hogyan állt az ember
mellett, hogyan állt oda az ember
oldalára. Tehát ő mindenkor az embernek
az ügyét képviselte, tehát mindenkor
kiállt az emberért. Ő volt az első, aki
úgymond, ha mostani nyelvezetre
lefordítjuk, tréninget hozott létre a
prostituáltak, a bűnözők, a az adószedők
a vámosoknak
az életében. Igazából a velük való
foglalkozás egy ilyen mély alá
támasztottsága mindannak, hogy hogyan
ott lenni az emberért, vagy hogyan
álljon ki az ember akár azért, hogy
önmagát képviselje, önmagát
megszaltassa, felszólaltassa egy nemes
szél érdekében, és hogy van helyreállító
munka és helyreállítási lehetőség. Én
ezeket a a részeket nézném, vagy ezt
szemlélném így egészbe, de na, meglássuk
így menet közben, hogy hogyan vomlik ki
a beszélgetés. Az utolsó kategóriaapont
ilyen szempontból jól bevezeti azt a
témakört, amiről szeretnék veled
beszélgetni. Az utolsó kategória az a
segítségkérés volt. Nagyon sok komment
érkezett és személyes megkeresés is,
hogy valahogy kösselek össze majd téged
a kommentelővel.
Sok segítségkérés arra vonatkozott, hogy
rendben van, felismertük. Tehát ott az
előző epizódot, hogyha most egy mondatba
kéne összefoglaljam, az az lenne, hogy
hogyan lehet felismerni mintázatok
alapján, hogy egy nárcisztikus
személlyel van kapcsolatunk, vagy egy
olyan helyzetbe kerültünk akár
munkahelyi környezetbe, ahol egy
nárcisztikus fél van jelen. Rendben
felismertük, de mit kezdünk ezzel? Tehát
konkrét praktikus tanácsokat kértek
tőlünk. Úgyhogy ezt az epizódot arra
szentelnénk,
hogy egyrészt hogyan tud valaki
megerősödni egy ilyen kapcsolatban, és a
másik milyen eszközeink vannak, hogy meg
tudjuk védeni magunkat. Ezekről
szeretnék egy kicsit beszélgetni és
akkor ezt vizsgáljuk meg, amennyi időnk
van, én szeretnék erre időt szánni.
Vizsgáljuk meg ezt több kontextusban,
például párkapcsolati kontext, ami ami
amúgy a túlnyomó többsége a a
kommentelők részéről párkapcsolatból
származott, vagy családi kontextusban,
ahol a szülő vagy akár a gyermek is.
Ilyen erre is volt példa, hogy a hogy
hogy a gyermeke volt az, aki
nárcisztikus
nárcisztikussá vált, és és így
bántalmazta úgymond a szüleit, és és a
munkahelyi körülmények. Tehát, hogy
akkor ezt, ahogy te szoktad használni
ezt a szétszálazást, szálazzuk szét
akkor ezt a a beszélgetést ebbe a három
irányba, és akkor vizsgáljuk meg, hogy
milyen eszközök vannak, amivel valaki
meg tud erősödni, és milyen eszközök
vannak, amivel meg tudja védeni magát
konkrétan. Mit szólsz hozzá? Igen,
nagyon jó ötletnek tartom. Mindenikhez
így külön-külön kapcsolódni fogok. Még
eszembe jutott egy gondolat a
visszajelzések alapján. többen írtak
személyes üzeneteket felém, és közölték,
hogy szeretnék megköszönni, hogy
keresztényként mertem vagy mertük ezt a
témát így boncolgatni, mert nagyon sok
keresztény úgy látja, hogy nincs kiállás
az áldozatokért, tehát nincsenek
emberek, akik felemelik azt, aki
végtelen állapotban van, és nincsen
megerősítés arra nézve, hogy hogyan
lépjenek tovább ők a bántalmazottak. És
ugye elég gyakran azt is érzékeltem így
az üzenetek mögött, hogy félreérthető
üzenetek vannak, akár hogy a hányszor
bocsássunk meg elvek alapján, meg a
bibliai
igék alapján, és hogy annyira jó volt
ezt látni, hogy keresik az emberek az
ilyen jellegű megoldásokat. És érdekes
módon olyan üzeneteket is kaptam, hogy
keresztény körökben ahogy mozognak,
tehát sok esetben keresztény párok
részéről is létrejön az, hogy az egyik
fél bántalmazó és a másik fél
félvilágosságra hozni, hogy hogyan
tovább, hogyha kiderül, hogy na ők egy
olyan család, akik egy bizonyos hit
mentén képviselik az életet, az
életútjukat keresztény szemlélettel, és
hogyan lehet tovább lépni jőnékig. Tehát
érdekes megkeresések vagy érdekes
rámírások voltak. Aztán volt olyan
igénykifejezés is, hogy nem-e lehetne
akár egy tábort szervezni, vagy akár
tréningeket szervezni, hogy hogyan
védjék meg önmagukat a bántalmazottak,
vagy hogyan álljanak ki, amikor
csak részleges határokat tudnak építeni,
mert éppen szülőpárokról van szó és több
megkeresés feleségek részéről érkezett
főként. Hát itt is egy picit itt
visszaigazolom azt, hogy tényleg a nők
nagyobb része vagy többsége el is indul
a megoldások keresésének az útján.
helyi ember helyi és külföldi is. Igen.
Külföldi is meglepő módon. Igen. És elég
sok is mondom azt, hogy nagyon örültek,
hogy ilyen szempontból vagy szemszögből
megközelítve. És amit érzékelek, ugye
ide megint behozom a a spirituális
lények is vagyunk ennek a fogalmát így a
pszichológia kapcsán akár, hogy mennyire
akarják a megoldást úgy keresni, hogy
nem csak horizontális síkon, hanem
vertikális síkon is. És rögtön eszembe
is jült egy gondolata a Gyökösi Endrének
így fogalmazott, hogy nem mindegy, hogy
kifele robbanok, befele robbanok, vagy
felfele robbanok. Tehát az, amikor
robbanhatunk fölfele, akkor kapunk egy
többleterőt. A befele robbanás az ugye
szétszed bennünket, széttör bennünket,
és az áldozatok nagyon gyakran a befele
robbanást alkalmaznák addig, amíg nem
indulnak el kifele egy segítségkérés
útján. És ezt is így jó volt látni, hogy
a fogózók és azok a helyzetek, amikor
már úgy tűnik, hogy falakba ütköztek,
még mindig hoznak egy kicsi rést a
falakon, és egy pici fénybe tudott
szűrődni, hogy csak van tovább, és az
Isten ad kegyelmet, hogy tovább
menjenek. Tehát nagyon nagy a keresés,
és azt látom, hogy nagyon nagy az igény
arra, hogy ne beleállni vagy megmaradni
abban, ami adatot. Tehát valahogy úgy
fogalmaznám, hogy a sorszerű mellé
Viktor Frankl szavaival élve nagyon
szeretem a logoterápia meg
egzisztenciaanalist. Azt is tanulom most
úgy próbálom egyre jobban beépíteni a a
tevékenységeimbe. Tehát adatott a
sorszerű, de megkeresni mellette azokat
a szabad területeket, ahol lehet az
embernek reménye, ahol még tud
kapcsolódni, ahol eldöntheti, hogy ő
mihez kapcsolódik. És valahol még az is
megfogalmazódott bennem, ahogy a a
kommentelőket olvasgattam, hogy a
sorsszerű valahol lehet egy sorsfordító
is, tehát adatik, ami adatik, de tehát
lehet, hogy arról nem tehetek, mert hogy
senki nem úgy megy bele, például egy
párkapcsolatba, hogy tudja, hogy ő ebbe
megy bele. vagy amit még kiemelnék, hogy
az elmúlt időben eléggé sokat
foglalkoztam még a témával, a
bántalmazottak oldaláról megközelítve,
megoldás lehetőségeket keresve. És ugye
az is szembe jött velem, hogy hát senki
nem gonosznak születik. a helyzetek, a
körülmények, a az ide a
megszületettségünk, egy családba
születettségünk ugye hozza létre azt,
hogy közben átalakul a személyiség, át
strukturálódik és amit érzékelek, tehát
így a párokkal való foglalkozás vagy a
párkapcsolatokban is, tehát a kiútm
meglelés valahol ezzel a
sorsfordító reményteli döntőképesség
fellelésével tud nagyon nagy
változásokat létrehozni, tehát az
egyénekben egyelőre. Ja, ez nagyon jó,
hogy megemítetted, hogy senki nem
gonosznak születik, így fogalmaztad,
mert több kommentellő pont ezt kérdezte,
hogy ez genetikailag örökölhető-e. És
ezt szerencsére, mármint utána jártam,
és én is így így gondolom, és remélem,
hogy te is egyetértesz, hogy ez nem
genetikai betegség, ez nem nem lehet az,
hogy édesapám az volt, és akkor lehet,
hogy bennem is megvannak a mindenképpen
megvan a hajlam, és bennem is megvan. És
emlékszem, ahogy az egyetemista éveim
első évében történt az a fordulat. Ha
nem fordul, akkor meg az életem, akkor
belőlem is egy remek nárcisztikus
válhatnott volna, egy manipulatív, egy
gázlángozó, egy egy ragadozó. És az,
hogy nem lettem nárcisztikus, az az több
mindennek köszönhető. Most abba nem
mennék bele, de én se vagyok mentes. És
lehet, hogy pont azért is vagyok ennyire
nyitott erre a témára, és ennyire
érzékeny, hogyha valaki mellettem
nárcisztikus jellenvonásokat mutat,
mert mert ez nem egy genetikai betegség,
ez
bárki belegy kereszthet
ebbe. Gondolom, hogy te is egyetértesz
ezzel. Ha nem genetikai, akkor akkor
hogyan lehet valaki hogyan lesz
valakiből nárcisztikus szerinted? Ugye
az első epizódnál beszéltünk arról, hogy
a család maga hogyan hat, tehát a
kötődésnek a kialakulása vagy a ki
nemalakulása. Ugye kiemeltem azt, hogy a
túlkényeztetett atmoszférából jövők,
vagy akár a ridg atmoszférából jövők és
mindenképp ez, ami így alátámasztja azt
gyakorlatilag bármelyik extrémum, amikor
mindent megkap és amitunk senkinek
semmit nem kap meg. valójában ilyenkor
azt látja, hogy ő ön magát kell akkor
felemelje és megvédje és és szeresse,
mert más nem teszi ezt. Pont pontosan.
És így alakul ki egy páncél, amivel
elkezdeni elkezdi védeni magát másként
másmilyen etikai alapelveket
alkalmazván, ami ugye nem fér bele a
normatív etikai alapelvekbe úgymond,
abba, ami egy rendszerbe besorolható,
úgymond.
Jó, hát akkor vágjunk is bele a témákba.
Az első rész az, hogy hogyan tudunk
megerősödni egy
ilyen kapcsolatban.
És ezt megelőzném azzal, hogy az egyik,
amit kaptam, így
legerősebb eszköz, amivel meg tudjuk
védeni magunkat, az, hogy bele se
megyünk egy ilyen kapcsolatba. Csak ez
nem egy túl jó praktikus tanács.
Nyilván, hogyha felismertük és
megtanultuk felismerni a a nárcisztikus
ellenvonásokat, akkor akkor ki tudjuk
alakítani magunkban azt a képességet,
hogy nemet mondjunk
időbe. Viszont mi van akkor, hogyha már
benne vagyunk, és egyszerűen nem tudunk
kimozdulni belőle, mert a szüleink azok,
mert mert a testvérem az, mert a párom
az, akivel már 10 éve házasak vagyunk,
és most döbbentem rá. Rengeteg
kommentellő azt mondta, hogy most kaptam
szavakat azokra a dolgokra, amiket eddig
nem tudtam megfogalmazni. Szóval mit
kezdjünk azokkal a helyzetekkel, amikor
már benne vagyunk, és már nem
tudjuk megfordítani, mármint valamit
kell kezdjünk a helyzettel, és azon
kapjuk magunkat, hogy már fáradtak
vagyunk, demotiváltak vagyunk, össze
vagyunk
zavarodva, depresszív hatások, akár
fizikai hatások jelennek meg, betegségek
jelennek meg, és és egyszerűen nem
kapjuk a a kiutat. Hol hol van ez a
felfele irányuló remény? Hogyan tudunk
megerősödni?
Úgy gondolom, hogy ugye ahogy kiemeltem,
hogy még mindig ott a szabad terület,
amiben lehet mozdítani az egyént előre.
És valahol úgy fogalmaznám meg, hogy a
közös út akkor ér véget, hogyha
megértsük és érezzük, átéljük. Minden
porcikánk már sajja szinte azt, hogy
méltatlan hozzánk. Tehát a közös út
akkor ér véget, amikor már méltatlan
hozzánk. Ugye egy kicsit komplex, hogy
ki mennyire tud teljesen lezárni egy
kapcsolatot, vagy részlegesen lezárni,
mert itt mindig kiemelem most már
másodjára itt is, hogy a szülőpárságot
teljesen lezárni nem lehet, mert egy
életen keresztül az a kapocs ott van,
hogy közösen mi szülők vagyunk, együvé
tartozók vagyunk, csak másmilyen módon
annak utána, miután tegyük föl, nem
működnek már együtt az utak, vagy
nincsen összekapcsolódása az utaknak,
amit kiemelek, tehát valahol az elidőzés
ugye abban, hogy nem stimmel az, hogy a
másiknak, a mellettem lévőnek, akár a
testvérnek, akár az anyának, akár a
szülőnek, bárkinek hatalma van fölöttem.
Tehát nem mindegy, hogy hatalommal él
valaki, vagy hatalma van valakinek.
Tehát ha van hatalom, a hatalmat jól is
lehet használni. Most érts jól. Tehát a
szülő hatalmát, autoritást, igen. Tehát
tudja szeretetre használni, tudja arra
használni, hogy becsületesség,
tisztelet, méltánylás átadása. Ugye a
hatalommal való visszaélést, vagy a
hatalmaskodást inkább talán ez a kulcszó
jobban talál. Lehet arra használni, hogy
visszaél az egyén azzal a státusszal,
amibe került éppen, vagy ami neki
adatott legyen szó, akár szülő, akár
párkapcsolatról.
És a visszaélés ugye az a méltány, tehát
a méltánylás nélküli állapot, ami
ledegradálja az egyént. És valahol úgy
érzékelem, hogy morál nélkül szétesik a
világ. Tehát hogyha nincs ott az a belső
erkölcsi morál, az az iránytű, egy
szétesettség van. És amikor azt látom,
hogyha valaki eljut oda, és egy picit
talán a gyászakaszokhoz tudnám
hasonlítani, hogy szükség valakinek
leskolódnia ahhoz, hogy elinduljon abba
az irányba, hogy na eddig és ne tovább.
Tehát itt ismét visszahozom ezt a
mondatot, hogy a morál nélküliség, tehát
hogy eddig és ne tovább, tehát ez már
nem fér bele abba, amit én képviselek.
Tehát a belső
emberképen ugye belénk van helyezve
mindannyiunkban egy tehát a
tisztpancsolat igazából fogalmazhatnák
így, hogy belénk van helyezve, mert hogy
hogyan egyértelmű azért az emberek nagy
részének különböző helyeken, különböző
helyeken élve, hogy hát ne ölj, ne lopj
satöbbi, ne törj házasságot. Ez azért
ott van az emberekben, akinél van egy
ilyen elfogadhatóbb, vagy akár egy ilyen
mélyen gondolkodó működés, hogy ezt így
magán átengedi, hogy ott a morálnak az
értéke, ott van az a keret, ami ad egy
védelmet, ad egy biztonságot. És amit
kiemelnék, én mindig úgy kapok reményt,
amikor találkozom emberekkel, akik nem
tudják, hogy hát hogyan is kezdjék el,
és ugye valahol pont ez volt a kérdésed,
hogy hát hogyan kezdjék, felismerték,
mit tegyenek, hogyan tovább. Én egy
picit az üdvtörténetbe próbálom őket
gondolkodtatni, tehát hogy a hogyan
tovább, tehát itt adatott, ami adatott,
de hogy mégis kaptak erőt, hogy
túléljék. És én el szoktam azokkal a
gondolatokkal időzni, hogy hogyan
erősödött meg arra nézve, hogy ő
túlélje, vagy hogyan volt neki
egyáltalán ereje, vagy mi segítette,
vagy mi volt az a csoda, ami hozzájárult
ahhoz, hogy ő segített legyen, vagy hogy
megsegített legyen azokban az időkben,
hogy valahol valahonnan csak jött egy
táplálék, hogy kibírtak sokan éveket, és
sokszor ugye évtizedekről beszélünk a
kommentekben is mennyire átjött, hogy
évtizedeket bírtak, és hogy most kezdik
felismerni, hogy miben voltak benne.
Tehát én ott tovább lépés
folytatását igazából ugye az
üttörténette még mindig van egy
történet, az én történetem, ami lehet
teljesebb, aminek lehet egy üdvös
kimenetele, lehet egy áldott
kimenetelem. És most így eszembe is jut
Böszörményi Nagyván, ő a kontextuális
terápiának a megalapítója, és ő mondta,
hogy az adok kapok egyensúlya is annyira
tetszik nekem, hogy egy családon belül
is, tehát nem csak jogaink, hanem
kötelezettségeink is vannak. És ugye
amikor felborul az egyensúly, tehát a
lélek az egyensúlyra törekszik. Mikor
felborul az egyensúly, akkor
ellensúlyozni kezd, és az ellensúlyozás
pont abban nyilvánul meg, hogy egy
kétségbeesés, vagy egy sok fázisba
belekerül az egyén a bántalmazott, és
azt érzi, hogy hát nem mehet ez így
tovább, meghaladja őt. És valahol ebből
jön ki az a sósfordító eseménynek az
útja is, a tovább lépés, a tovább
delegáltságnak az útja.
Tehát gyakorlatilag azt mondod, hogy
amikor felismeri az ember azt, hogy ez a
helyzet, amiben vagyok, ez ez nem csak,
hogy rossz nekem, hanem helytelen. Tehát
méltatlan ez a ez a helyzet velem
szemben. Ez e ez az érzés, hogy
méltatlan, ez ad reményt, mert azt
jelenti, hogy van bennem valami belső
morális iránytól, ami még működik.
És igen, amúgy ez az érdekes ezzel
kapcsolatban, hogy én is ezt
tapasztaltam a a környezetemben levő
nárcisztikusokkal szemben, hogy nem
értik az
alapelveket, hogy használják, mert
sokszor utalnak a Bibliára, sokszor
utalnak olyan dolgokra, amik alapelvnek
tűnnek, de ugye ahogy az előző epizódban
is említettem, az első alkalommal,
amikor nem éri meg nekik, vagy amikor
pont szembemegy az ő érdekeikkel, akkor
pont kifordítják azt az alapelvet. Tehát
nem nincs meg a kellő alázat bennük,
hogy alávessék magukat ezeknek az
alapelveknek. És most gyakorlatilag arra
utaltál, és amúgy nagyon tetszik, hogy
de ennek ellenére vannak alapelvek,
akárhogy tagadják a nárcisztikusok,
akárhogy próbálják a saját realitásunkat
átmozgatni, át tehát zavart kelteni
bennünk, mégis bele tudunk kapaszkodni
abba, hogy valami belül mégis azt
mondja, hogy ez méltatlan, hogy ez
helytelen. ami történik, van egy helyes
útja, tehát hogy gyakorlatilag, ha
helytelen, akkor azt jelenti, hogy
létezik egy helyes útja, hogy hogyan
kéne ezt jól csinálni. Pontosan. És egy
ige jut eszembe itt a kérdésed meg a
visszajelzésed kapcsán, hogy azt mondja
az ige, hogy a megroppant nádat nem töri
össze, és a füstölgő mécsbelet nem oltja
el. És az Istennek tényleg az a terve,
hogy amikor valaki már ott a
megroppanásba, vagy a füstölgő mécsbél
állapot megélésbe, tehát nem az a cél,
hogy teljes összetöretés vagy
megroppanás legyen, meg teljes elalélás
legyen, ott fakad föl a méltóság, hogy
hát több való hozzám, vagy több illik
hozzám, több vagyok, mint a
determináltsága mindannak, ami eddig
jutott nekem. Tehát nem determinál engem
az, ami eddig jutott, hanem ott meg tud
nyílni egy ajtó, egy kap. Tehát több
vagyok, mint a sorseseményeknek az
összessége. Tehát ott ez az erő tud
feltörni, hogy több vagyok, ismétlem
magam, mint a sorseseményeknek az
összessége. És ott már nem egy
determinisztikus látás van jelen, hanem
tovább nyílnak az ajtók, mertogy amikor
már felismerem, hogy méltatlan hozzám a
helyzet, hát azt csak egy belső erővel
lehet felismerni. Hát ha nem tör föl egy
belső energiaforrás, egy belső
vízcsobogás, úgymond, nem tud megnyílni
az út. Tehát arra, hogy én hol vagyok,
nem tudom definiálni, és akkor csak azt
fog meghatározni, hogy hát én az vagyok,
amit eddig kaptam. És amit érzékelek,
hogy sokszor nem tudják, amíg nem jön ez
az erő létre, ez az erőtér,
megnyilvánulás létre, úgymond nem tudják
leválasztani az egyének magukat a
narcisztikus aspektussral bírónak a
működéséről. azt gondolják, hogy az a
működés ők, tehát ők azt azért kapják,
merthogy ők rosszak most egy kicsit így
szólván úgymond. És meghatározza őket,
determináltá teszi őket. És amikor ugye
felismerésön, hogy de több vagyok, mint
az eddigi eseményeknek a végösszege, ami
most látszik, akkor jön az a belső
felfakadás, hogy na eddig és ne tovább.
És én ennek annyira örülök, és általában
én ezekkel a személyekkel találkozom,
akik így jönnek, hogy eddig és ne
tovább. És olyan érdekes, mert nagyon
gyakran hallom, hogy egy szűrőn már
átmentek ezek a személyek, hogy ha már
ha már megkerestek téged, azt jelenti,
hogy egy döntést hoztak az életan is.
Úgy jönnek oda, hogy már nagyon
informáltak, tehát nagyon sok videót
végighallgattak, mindent kívülről tudnak
mondhatni
lexikálisan. Vannak ismereteik,
pszichológiai ismereteik, csak ugye
megerősödni a belső emberükbe ez az, ami
ott még hiány rész. és azt próbálják,
vagy azt próbáljuk így a közös munka
eredményeként létrehozni, hogy
megerősítessen a belső emberkép, hogy
nem az vagyok, ami eddig látszott, vagy
amit eddig nekem mondtak, hogy én az
vagyok, mert ugye nagyon erősen rájuk
helyeződik egy kényszerzubony a
bántalmazó félrészéről, és úgy határozza
meg őket a kényszerzubony, hogy
fölteszik maguknak a kérdést, hogy vajon
tényleg igaz-e, amit nekem mondanak?
Vajon tényleg én ez vagyok? És amikor
eljönnek, ott már tudják, hogy nem ez
vagyok, ott a vég. A vég, ami valaminek
a kezdete. Igen. Igen. A ezzel
kapcsolatban most van egy pár
gondolatom. A az egyik az, hogy kaptam
egy csodálatos idézetet ezzel
kapcsolatban, hogy az áldozatokban
sokszor ott van az az érzés,
hogy hogy már el 20 évet eltöltöttem az
életemben, most már mindegy. De e volt
egy csodálatos idézet, hogy a legjobb
pillanat arra, hogy egy fát ültess, az
20 évvel ezelőtt volt. A második legjobb
pillanat az most.
És h amikor ez az idézet számomra azt
mondja, hogy tényleg sokkal jobb lett
volna az életem, hogyha 20 évvel ezelőtt
rájöttem volna arra, amit most tudok, de
most rájöttem, mit kezdek ezzel? És ez
tényleg egy egy reményt adó valami, hogy
a nem vagyok determinált. A
jövőm nincs determinálva azáltal, hogy
mit éltem 20 év. Nyilván hatással van,
tehát hogy azt a
csomagot azért felelősséget kell
vállaljak, mert én is igen mondtam,
bizonyos dolgokat megtettem és hagytam,
hogy megtörténjen velem. Áldozat voltam
és tényleg fájdalmas az, amit túl
átéltem, meg kell gyászoljam, de mit
kezdek ezzel? És ez már a
reménytadórész, ami ami tetszik. És a
másik, hogy bátorító bátorításként
akarom mondani a hallgatók számára, hogy
az egyik legtöbb kritika, amit én
kaptam, amikor legelőször felfedeztem a
környezetemben egy ilyen nárcisztikus
személyt és szembentem vele, nagyon sok
kritikát kaptam azzal kapcsolatban, hogy
nem vagyok szakember. Hogy veszem én a
bátorságot, hogy címkézzek valakit,
hogyha nem vagyok szakember? És én most
így az elmúlt két hét alatt, ameddig
intenzíven készültem erre az epizódra,
jöttem rá, hogy álljon meg a menet. egy
annyi tudást összeszedtem, hogy
szerintem egy egyetemi alapképzéssel
felír. Úgyhogy nem, bár tényleg nem
nincs diplomám ezzel kapcsolatban,
de de mégsem mondhatom azt, hogy nem
értek hozzá. Legalább szavaim nincsenek
rá. Nem nem biztos, hogy mindent jól
értek és minden kutatást átolvasnam, de
azért úgy nagyjából jól belőttem. És ezt
tudom a bátorításként ajánlani minden
egyes hallgatónak, hogy érdemes ezzel
foglalkozni, érdemes ezt felismerni,
mert mert egy idő után megismerjük és
egy idő után a mesterévé tudunk válni
ennek a témának. És amikor elmegyünk
beszélgetni egy egy szakemberrel, akkor
egyrészt a szakember le tudja
ellenőrizni a tudásunkat. Ez egy fontos
dolog, de a másik az, hogy már nem onnan
indulunk, hogy az alapokat kell
megtanítsa az a szakember, hanem
elkezdünk tudni beszélgetni, mit kezdünk
akkor ezzel a tudással tovább. Itt mi
hova építkezünk ezután?
Igen, teljesen egyetértek. Edukációs
rész nélkül amúgy nem lehet. Tehát
mindig egy-egy pici edukáció azért csak
bekerül, amit érzékelek nálad, és úgy
örülök, hogy ezt te így megélted meg
tapasztalatból is ugye behozod ezt a a
megélésedet, úgymond, hogy
forrásorientációkat próbáltál
megragadni, tehát orientálódtál,
kerested a forrásokat, és hogy azért
volt neked is arra szükséged,
feltételezem, de ha nem így van,
nyugodtan korrekcionálj, kérlek, hogy el
tudjál igazodni abban a pusztában, amibe
belekerültél, mert bevonja a lábait az
egyénnek egy pusztaságba az az állapot,
ami körülötte zajlik, és hogy
érthetetlen az a puszta, tehát nem leli
a kiutat, csak az, hogy egy nagy puszta,
ennyi látszódik meg belőle, de hogyan
tovább a nagy pusztába. És tényleg a
forrásorientációk, ugye a a történetem
csak folytatódhat másként is. Valahol
egy picit úgy fogalmaznám meg, hogy a
reményt összekötöm a szabadakarattal.
Benne van a szabadakaratom a reményben.
Itt jelenik meg egy forrás, felfakasztás
a pusztában. És ugye eszembe is jut ez
az ige, hogy ime én újat cselekszem,
mosarjat, talán nem tudjátok, utat
készítek a sivatagba, pusztába pedig
folyókat. Én meg vagyok győződve, hogy
amikor orientálódom egy-egy téma
kapcsán, akkor folyókat tudok készíteni
a saját pusztámban akár vagy másoknak a
pusztájának a megélésében is. Ott tudok
lenni úgy, mint egyfajta forrásfakasztó.
És ez a remény ugye, hogy
összekapcsolható a szabad akarattal is
csak úgy tud stabilizálódni az egyén meg
az embernek az élete, a bántalmazottnak
az élete, hogyha valamiben
sziklaszilárdanál. És ugye az Isten
szeretete az egy konstans valami, tehát
ahhoz igazíthatom magamat, hogy nem
kérdés, hogy ő ő azt szeretné-e, hogy
megépült legyek, nem kérdés, hogy azt
szeretné-e, hogy tovább vigye az
egyénnek az élethútját.
Amit érzékelek. Említetted ugye így a
kutakodásaid kapcsán, hogy már fölérne
egy alapképzéssel akár a te kutakodásod,
ez idáig az utad. Én nagyon tudok örülni
annak, amikor valaki ennyire komolyan
elmélyül abban, hogy nem csak események
sokasága vesz körül, nem csak ránk
hatnak az események, hanem annak az
eseménynek valamilyen megszólítottsága
is lehet az én életemben. És mindenkor
úgy össze tudom kapcsolni, hogy és már
néha izgalommal is várom, hogy az a
megszólítottság vajon mire való
felszólítottságot fog kimunkálni az
egyénnek az életébe, mert minden
megszólítottság mögött ott van egy
kiszólítottság, és kiszólítódom abból a
megszokott szférából, a fájdalmi
szférából és a kiszólítottságból jön
létre a felszólítottság. felszólítódom
egy nemesebb életfeladatra, egy nemesebb
életcél vagy életút betöltésére. És ugye
ahogy az imént fogalmaztam, ugye, hogy
több vagyok, mint az eddigi
történéseimnek az összessége. Van út,
tovább, van három pont, nem egy nagy
pont lett a vége mindannak, ami addig
történt. Amit a kutakodásaid kapcsán még
kiemelnék, hogy nagyon tág a
nárcisztikusság témájának a
pszichológiája. Tehát el is tudunk
veszni a részletekbe. Ugye azért is
jöttem vissza azzal a reménnyel, hogy
nem az a cél, hogy ezt bogozzuk, hogy
hogyan működnek. A múltkor ki volt
emelve elég sok minden. Nagyon nagy az
anyag az interneten is, ami elérhető.
Különböző előad előadóktól nagyon jó
anyagok lelhetőek föl, hanem inkább az a
fókusz, hogy hogyan tovább azoknak, akik
megéltek ilyen kapcsolódásokat. Tehát
nem egy tág
valamiben szeretnénk itt most elveszni
úgymond, hanem megragadni egy-egy pici
részt úgy, ahogy tudjuk, azzal a
töredékes, töredelmes emberképpel, meg
azzal, ahogy itt vagyunk. De hogy
mindenképp úgy érződjön, hogy a szándék,
amit képviselni szeretnünk az ittlétben,
az valahol az, hogy a továbbívő útnak a
felemelkedése és a továbbvivő útnak a
kibontakozása, meg az arra való
rálátatás, hogy van megoldás, nem
határol be, meghatároz, de nem határol
be. Tehát nincs, ahogy ne határozzon
meg. Tehát évekig tartó fájdalmas
kapcsolatok, akár egy vezető részéről,
akár ugye egy egyházi személy részéről,
mert több ilyen üzenet is volt, hogy
egyházi személyek voltak bántalmazóak
velük szemben, akár vagy akár férfeleség
kapcsolat, vagy legyen szó szülőgyerek
bármilyen kapcsolatról, tehát
meghatároz, de nem határol be. nem
határol be, tehát nincs, ahogy ne hasson
rám, merthogy érintett érintett fél
vagyok, de hogy tovább tudok abba lépni,
és ahogy mondtad, hogy te is amikor
érintett fél voltál, akkor kezdtél el
kutakodni eme téma iránt. És milyen mély
az a felismerésed, hogy volt egy pont az
egyetemi éveidben, hogy úgy érezted,
hogy válhatnál akár azzá, de nem élsz
vissza mindazzal, ami adatot. És ide
visszahozom azokat a fogalmakat, ugye,
hogy ahogy élek a hatalommal, vagy
visszaélek, adatot valami, tehát élhetek
szeretettel azzal a hatalommal is. Ugye
nagyon sokszor vezető emberek töltik be
sajnos ezeket a a működésmódozatokat,
akár a nárcisztikus aspektusságnak a
működése ugye a vezetőkhöz nagyon
kapcsolható. Nagyon sok esetben a
grandiózitás főként igen, grandiózus
énképpel bíróknál, de hogy élek a
hatalommal vagy visszaélek, te nem
visszaélni akartál azzal a hatalommal,
hanem jól élni vele. Tehát igen, adatott
egy felelősség. És itt egy picit a
hatalmat talán lebontanám a felelősség
irányára is. Tehát felelősség adatot,
vagy hatalommal való visszaélés adatot,
tehát ha felelősséget érzékel az egyén.
És ugye itt behoztam azt, hogy a morál
nélküliség szétesik a világunk. Tehát a
rendek, a rendszerek azok érettünk
vannak. A rendszernek van egy hatalma
arra, hogy megtartson, ha szeretettel
teszi azt. De a rendszernek tud lenni
egy lealása, hogyha nincs benne ott az a
szeretet a háttérbe, az ember értékét
képviselvén. Igen. Így a ami eszembe
jutott ezzel kapcsolatban, amit mondtál,
hogy egyrészt így az elmúlt fél évben
nagyon figyeltem arra, hogy azok a közeg
közegek, ahol mozgok, menedzsment és
felső vezetési közeg, hogy milyen
hatalmas nyomással nyom néha engem is és
mást is. Az a felelősség, amit amit
vinnem kell, néha összeroppant, az az
igazság. És elgondolkoztam azon, hogyha
én, mint egy egy kicsi vagy egy
középvállalkozás, közepes méretű
vállalkozásnak a vezetője,
ennyire nagy nyomásnak élemsz meg? Mi
lehet egy állam
akár az államelnöke most a választások
kapcsán, vagy vagy egy egy sokkal
nagyobb szervezetnek az élén levő
személye, hogy tudja elviselni azt a
terhet. És arra jöttem rá, hogy
valójában kétféleképpen lehet ezt
elviselni. Az egyik az, hogy vagy
hiperkompetenssé válok és képes vagyok
arra, hogy hogy a a nyomással együtt
elég kompetens vagyok ahhoz, hogy ezt
végigvigyem, vagy egyszerűen nem
foglalkozom vele. Tehát ugye ahogy egy
grandiózus nárcisztikus, aki kiáll és a
a teljesen természetesnek veszi, hogy az
autoritással járó előnyöket, azokat az
azok azok, mint a levegő körbegye őt, és
és teljesen rendben van ez neki, és
különösebben nem foglalkozik a
következményekkel. Egyszerűen úgy, ahogy
egy párkapcsolatban a a nárcisztikus fél
nem foglalkozik azokkal a bántásokkal,
amiket nem nem foglalkozik a
következményekkel, amik amik az ő
életét
tehát a a a viselkedését
követi. Ö, szóval, hogy hogy csak így
lehet túlélni kétféleképpen, vagy az
van, és a hatalmi pozíciók vonzák emiatt
a nárcisztikus személyeket, mert nagyon
kevés hiperkompetens személy van, és
több nárcisztikus, aki aki viszont be
tudja tölteni, ha megüresedik egy
pozíció, egy lehetőség, akkor valójában
ez a két kategória az, aki aki versenyez
ezért a pozícióért. És a másik dolog,
ami most eszembe jutott, hogy nagyon
tetszik a téma, amilyen irányba
elindultunk.
Szóval a személy a szenvedésén keresztül
felismerte, hogy hol van, és felismerte
a reményt, vagyis a fájdalmat, ami
reményt is
hoz. Amit még javasoltál, az az, hogy
érdemes ilyenkor egy terapeutát
megkeresni, vagyis pontosabban akik
megkeresnek téged, erre a
következtetésre jutottak. De szerintem
is érdemes, mert valójában egy jó
terapeuta visszajelzést ad számunkra,
hogy amiben benne vagyunk, az valós-e
vagy nem valós. Hogy magunknak
képzeljük-e be, úgy ahogy tegyük fel a
partnerünk, vagy akár a főnökünk
folyamatosan mondja, hogy mi képzeljük
be, és a probléma azok mi vagyunk, vagy
pedig nem.
Viszont itt az a probléma, hogy amikor
és jó is az én példám, amikor én a
pusztába bolyongtam ezzel a témával, és
kerestem a válaszokat, kerestem még két
mások terapeutát előtted, amiőtt még
téged hívtalak volna fel, két másik
terapeutával beszéltem telefonon, és
vissza kellett rettenjek attól, hogy
hogy leüljek velük beszélgetni. Az első
azt mondta, hogy hát három-négy hónap
múlva tud fogadni, ami még nem is lenne
baj, mert talán ez a ez a jelzése annak,
hogy lehet, hogy tényleg egy jó
terapeuta, de éreztem a beszélgetés
alapján, hogy fogalma sincs, hogy mi az
a nárcizmus. Tehát lehet, hogy tudja,
mint szó mit jelent, de miközben
beszélgettem vele,
teljesen hidegen kezelt, és láttam, hogy
fogalma sincs, hogy hogy én most milyen
pusztában vagyok pontosan. És ugyanez
történt a második terapeutával is. És az
az érzésem, hogy attól, hogy valaki
elvégezte az alapképzést az egyetemen, a
pszichológiai egyetemen, és tegyük fel,
volt két-három kurzus erről, vagy vagy
két-három pár órás képzés magáról, nem
tudom, hogy há mennyit tanulnak a
nárcizmusról a az egyetemen hivatalosan.
A a valahogy mintogyha az lenne, hogy az
emberek nem értik, hogy mi ez a
nárcizmus. Tehát, hogy
hallják, intellektuálisan felfogják, de
nem mélyen nem értik meg. Tehát az, aki
bele nem kerül egy ilyen kapcsolatba,
egyszerűen nem érti. És amikor jön egy
ilyen aha pillanat, hogy jaj, erről volt
szó, ez az, most már értem, most már
értem, hogy miről szól a nárcizmus.
Valahogy kell egy ilyen bekattanjon
valami a fejembe. És ez is történt az én
esetemben. És amiután kerestem a
terapeutákat, rájöttem arra,
hogy ezeknek a személyeknek nem kattant
be. hiába, hogy nem tudom milyen neves
terapeuták lehetnek. Sőt, még utána volt
még pár másik
ilyen ilyen nyomás rajtam, hogy a az
ismerőseim, akik ugyancsak járnak
pszichológushoz, ugyanezt a témát
megkelletemen visszik valahogy. És az ő
terapeutájuk üzente nekem, hogy és üzent
egy jó pár dolgot, hogy nem vagyok
pszichológus, nem szabad ítélkezek, nem
szabad címkézzek és mind olyan dolgokat
mondtak, hogy nekem az volt az érzésem,
hogy rendben, de ezzel nem tudok mit
kezdeni. Tehát attól még a helyzet itt
van, valahogy meg kell oldani. És
fogalmam sincs, hogy ki a mi a tehát
igazi segítséget nem nyújtott az, hogy
kívülről ítélkeztek. Úgyhogy úgyhogy ezt
akarnám a megerősödés útján javasolni.
És kíváncsi vagyok, hogy ezt ezt te is
alá tudod-e írni, hogy válasszák meg azt
a terapeutát, keressék meg azt a
személyt, akivel amikor leülnek, békét
éreznek, nyugalmat éreznek, és azt
érzik, hogy ez a személy levegőt ad a
lelkének. Tehát, hogy
ilyen érti, te jó ég, van valaki, aki
meghallotta a hangomat, érti, és nem
kell magyarázkodja folyamatosan neki.
Igen. Amit érzékelek, hogy a
személyiségzavaroknak önmagába véve
nagyon komplex a működése, és egy picit
tényleg van óckodás attól, hogy
belemenjünk ebbe mélyebben. Én ugyanem
terapeutai státuszban vagyok, hanem
segítő beszélgetéseket, pszichoedukatív
beszélgetéseket tartok. De hogy tehát én
abból az irányból próbálom
megközelíteni, hogy a folytatás afelé
vagy annak a személynek a részére hogyan
ragadható meg, aki benne van abban,
amiben éppen benne van, és felismert
valamit, amit éppen felismert, és úgy
ahogy mondod, hogy szerintem
mindenikőnek vagy terapeutának, vagy
pszichológusnak, úgy eljön az az idő,
hogy na igen, most már még inkább értem,
valahol úgy szembe találkozik, mert hogy
tényleg annyi mindennel menet közben
szembe találkozásaink vannak azoknak,
akik segítői területeken mozognak, vagy
akár ugye én nagyon gyakran kiemelem azt
is, hogy a támogató családi közeg is
akkora segítség tud lenni, hogy nem
szükség ahhoz valakinek épsegítő
szakembernek lennie, hogyha ott egy
támogató családi kőzeg, én olyan
csodákat láttam meg, hogy összefogtak a
nehéz időkben, és hogy összezárt a
család, és nem engedték meg, hogy
szétesés vagy kiesés legyen. És olyan
érdekes, mert hallottam, hallottam, hogy
Indiában amikor valakinek van egy ilyen
pszichés rendellenes megnyilvánulása,
úgymond összefog az összes felmenői
vonalban lévő, vagy aki még élő úgymond,
és elkezdenek tanácskozni arról, az
egész rokonsága a perputja úgymond
elkezd tanácskozni arról, hogy vajon mi
leelhette az egyént, és ők hogyan
tudnának beindulni azért, hogy egy
teljes rendszeren belül ott tényleg a
teljes rendszeren belül
megépülése tudjon lenni az egyének, és
ugye a rendszernek a védelme, a családi
rendszernek a védelme, vagy a akár a
baráti körnek a védelme. És tényleg,
amit ugye említettek, vagy üzentek az
ismerőseidtől a szakemberek, nem lehet
stigmatizálni, tehát tényleg nem
diagnózisokat felállítani, kimondani, de
az, hogy felismertünk valamit és abban
mi erősödünk, tehát az már egy óriási
segítség. Úgyhogy ez lenne a realitását
nem szabad tagadni annak a szemé, hogy
mit tapos pontosan. Pontosan csak nem az
a feladat és tényleg nem az, hogy
ítélkező módon stigmákkal élvén. Tehát
nem megítélhetem, hogy a működés káros,
rám nézve, ránk nézve, bárkire, aki
érintett káros, de nem ítélkezhetem és
főként nem süthetek rá stigmát, hogy ő
aztán az, mert ugye én mostanában
tényleg azt láttam, hogy mindenkire
nagyon könnyen rásütik ezt a bélyeget,
hogy a narcisztikus nincs vele mit
foglalkozni, a narcisztikus nincs vele
mit foglalkozni. Tehát úgy valahogy
kiemelném, hogy lássuk meg azt is, hogy
igen, lehet, hogy az, de nem azok
vagyunk,
akik diagnosztizálhatunk, vagy én
legalábbis semmiképp nem is, hogy ugye
sokan tényleg nem, de hogy felismerni
azt, hogy az ami, de hogy a mögöttő
ember is, és egy picit az emberre
ránézni, tehát nem maga a Sátán, de hogy
egy ember, és az embert hogy tudom úgy
nézni, hogy a mellette lévő, a
segítséget kérő mégis csak azt érezze,
hogy voltak szép pillanatok együtt, és
voltak olyan időszakok, amikor össze
tudtak kapcsolódni. Tehát én inkább ezt
az emberi részt ragadnám meg, de nem
úgy, hogy belerakni annak a fejét egy
járomba, vagy belehelyezni egyába, hogy
tűrjél életed végéig, és neked ez
jutott. Tehát nem ott már egy ellenálló
képességgel, egy kitörési képességgel,
ugye általában tényleg ez így
kirajzolódik. előtör az életerő belőlük,
a változásra való vágyakozás belőlük
ugye a pusztában lét, ahogy
megfogalmaztam, a te helyzetedben is
csak előtör és vágyakoznak a víz után,
de hogy mégis legyen ott egy józan
differenciálódási képesség, vagy
differenciálási képesség, hogy nem.
Tehát eddig tartott ez az út például
beszéljünk akkor tovább erről az
ellenálló képességnek a megerősítéséről.
Hogyan tudja valaki? És akkor itt lehet
most az konkrét
szétszálazás jöhetne, hogy hogyan tudja
valaki megerősíteni az ellenálló
képességét, hogyha a partnere, a
házastársa, tegyük fel egy nárcisztikus
fél, rájövünk 10 év házasság után, mit
kezdünk ezzel? Az egyik, amit kiemelnék,
a lehetőségek mindannyiunk számára
adottak, tehát a nárcisztikus
aspektussal működőkre is adottak a
lehetőségek a változtatásra nézve, csak
mivel ők a külső páncélt annyira
megtanulták hordani magukon, hogy bennük
ez nincs ott egy mély vágyként, egy
mélyített vágyként, hogy jó lenne
alakítani, vagy akár változtatni,
módosítani az addigi életformán,
életvitelen.
Mit kiemelnék így ezzel kapcsolat
kapcsolatosan, hogy az intetlen az
menthetetlen, tehát az menthető, aki
intető. És ugye ilyen érdekes
kifejezések vagy kulcszavak, nagyon
szeretek kulcszavakba gondolkodni. Tehát
ha inthető valaki helyre tud állni az
útja és menthetővé válik az útja, de az
inthetetlen ember sajnos tényleg
menthetetlenné válik. És így eszembe is
ott megint egy ige az összeomlást
gőgelőzi meg, de a tisztesség előtt
alázat jár. Tehát mindenkor az
összeomlást megelőzi egy gők. Tehát
előbb-utóbb egy összeomlás valahol a
vége, egy megtöretés. De hogy nincsen
ott az a lehetőség, hogy ők tudják
fogadni azt, hogy inthetővé válni, vagy
nagyon kevés személynél van ott, és ugye
ezért megy a fókusz arra, hogy de akkor
a mellette lévő hogyan menthető? És
olyan érdekes, mert ugye a mellette
lévők az áldozatokk a bántalmazottak, ők
a felismerésnek az emberevé válnak.
Előbb-utóbb igen, én annyiszor
rácsodálkoztam, hogyha de mi adott erőt
nekik eddig, és hogy ők ezt kibírták és
a felismerés emberevé váltak, és valahol
az intetőségnek az ereje, hogy hát én
még menteni akarok valamit. Hát lehet,
hogy 40 évet éltem ott, de ugye ahogy
mondtad, a faültetés példájával
kapcsolatosan, tehát a legjobb pillanat
20 évvel ezelőtt, vagy akár most, mert
20 év múlva abból még valami terebélyes
kinőhet, vagy formálódhat. De ebben az
is benne van, amit mondtál, hogy tehát
az inthető, a menthető. Viszont hogyha
rájöttem, hogy ez a másik személy
mellettem nem inthető, akkor nem
menthető. Az itt legalábbis általam nem
menthető. Ez egy fontos felismerés, mert
tényleg évtizedeken keresztül
reménykedünk abban, hogy a másik szemét
meg fogom tudni változtatni, csak ha
elég jól szeretem, hogyha a hajamat egy
kicsit másképp hordom, hogyha ha
finomabbakat főznék, és a másik személy
folyamatosan mondja is, hogy most ez nem
tetszett, az nem tetszett, így kell
változál. És egy idő után azt látom,
hogy már magamra se ismerek,
annyiféleképpen változtam, és mégsem
változik a másik személy. És talán mégis
benne van ez a bölcsesség, hogy nem a mi
feladatunk a másik személyt megváltani,
nem a mi feladatunk
megmenteni. Lehetünk ebbe partnerek, de
valójában az belülről kell jöjjön. És az
egyik legfőbb kérdés talán a kommentek
között ez volt, hogy van-e remény, hogy
hogy változon a másik személy? Meg
tudom-e változtatni én, vagy fog-e
változni? Tud-e változni? Ez a k tud-e
változni egy nárcisztikus szfér? Amit
megértettem, az azt az azzal egyetértek
én is, hogy elméletben tud, tehát hogy
megvan az ő belső szabadsága arra, hogy
változzon, hogyha akar.
Itt a másik kérdés az, hogy akar-e, és
ez már lehet, hogy nem a mi feladatunk
partnerként, hogy hogy az akaratot
úgymond elültessük benne. Én amit
kiemelnék, hogy felelősség fölvállalás
elsősorban önmagunkért, és úgy
fogalmaznék, hogy a méltósághoz való
jogunkért és jogainkért álljunk ki.
Tehát, hogy ő változik-e, az az ő
felelőssége, hogy ő vállalja-e azt, ami
azzal járna, hogy változás legyen, mert
úgy vagyunk alkotva, hogy változásra
készek és képesek ké tétettünk, úgymond,
de én elsősorban, mi elsősorban a
méltósághoz való jogainkért és jogunkért
tudunk kiállni. És itt kiragadnám azt,
hogy az életben bármit elvehetnek
tőlünk, és hogy ez szintén Viktor
Franknek az elmélete, ugye túlélte ő az
ausvici tábort, és meggyőződése volt, és
így is élte túl, nyilatkozik erről, de a
belső szabadságot azt nem vehetik el.
Tehát bármit elvehetnek tőlünk, de a
belső szabadságunkat nem. Tehát itt már
túl szükséges lépni és nézni azon, hogy
a mellettem lévő változik-e. És ez nem
azt jelenti, hogy leteszem önmagamról a
felelősséget, mert aki kitartott 40 éven
keresztül egy párkapcsolatban, épp ez
tükröződik vissza a kitartásából, hogy
nagyon nagy felelősséget vállalt be
annak érdekébe, vagy azzal a céllal, na
hátha holnap, na hátha jövőre, na hátha
fog változni, kitartok. És ugye valahogy
vissza tudnak menni a múltra olyan módon
és a múltban időzni olyan módon, hogy de
hányszor is volt már az, hogy de kedves
volt velem, hát elvitt engem valahová,
figyelmes volt, újból nem tudom,
észrevette az igényeimet, betöltette a
szükségeimet, udvarolt, visszajelzett
egy adott ponton, amikor már felfakad az
a belső erő, hogy önmagamért vállalom a
felelősséget, most már pusztán
önmagamért, és ha kiértékeljük és
visszatekintéseket ejtünk meg, akkor
Akkor valahol érződik az, hogy de hány
évet vártunk arra, hogy legyen egy
változás. Tehát itt arra menne rá a
fókuszom, és főként arra megy rá a
fókuszom, hogy már nem érette, hanem
önmagamért a felelősségvállalás. És
amikor egy egyén önmagáért bevállalta,
akkor az érette valót, a másokért valót
már másként kezdi el látni. Ott már
határokba kezd
elgondolkodni, hol van az én határom. És
olyan érdekes az a szó, hogy határok.
Tudom mostanában nagyon sokat
boncolgatott téma is valahol. Nem hiába,
hogy most jött be ennyire így a a
szférába, mindennapi szférába, úgymond
hat árok, tehát az
etimológiai szavaknak az etimológiájában
nagyon szeretek foglalkozni. Hat árok,
tehát hat árkot ások, csak hogy éppen
köztünk legyen egy távolság, úgymond egy
megfelelő távolság. És amikor valaki ezt
így már megérzi, vagy érzékeli, és már
ott a belső nyomás, ugye, ahogy mondtam,
hogy a lélek, hogyha nem kapja meg az
egyensúlyt, akkor ellensúlyt kezd el
képezni. Tehát ez a határok is valahol
egy felkiáltó szó, hogy ássunk árkokat,
legyünk megfelelő távolságban egymástól.
És amikor ennek a felismerése és
észlelése létrejön, és ugye az
edukációs formáknak a megragadása, ott
már az egyénnek elkezd erősödni az
önmagáról alkotott képe, és ott már nem
jön egy ilyen hamis felelősség létre,
mert igen, én merem hamis felelősségnek
nevezni, hogy túlúl bevállalok a
mellettem lévő felnőttér bármit is. Vagy
sokan úgy voltak, hogy elmondták, hogy
hányszor tapasztalták meg, vagy élték
meg, hogy belevitte őket egy hazugságba,
és hogy ők kiálltak am mellett, mert
hogy ő megkérte, hogy de akkor te is
mondd azt, hogy és hogy ez milyen
dinamikát hordoz, ugye, hogy belülről
csak megszólal az a belső érzés, az az
erkölcsi iránytő, amiről beszéltünk, a
morális etikai iránytő úgy mondta, hogy
de várjál, hát én mibe keveredtem akkor
bele? Hát mibe von bele? és mikor
fordítottan szükséges, hogy tegyük fel ő
álljon ki a bántalmazott mellett, akkor
nincs ott az a kiállás, hanem te vagy a
hibás, te szúrtad el satöbbi. Tehát
szükség ennek a dinamikájára azért így
rálátnunk teljesebben.
Igen. Igen. A emögött még ezt azt az
alapelvet említeném meg,
hogy ki kell alakuljon bennünk egy ilyen
radikális
elfogadás,
hogy ha ez így is maradna, ha ez a
személy nem változna, akkor tudjam
elfogadni, hogy hogy ő ilyennél vált,
vagy ő nem akar változni. És ez egy
gyász, mert valójában az van, hogy amit
én tapasztalok, főleg vezetőként, hogy
sosem az embert látom, hanem az ember és
a benne levű potenciált egyszerre, hogy
mivé válhat. És ilyenkor, amikor például
egy junior fejlesztővel dolgozok együtt,
akkor sosem csak a juniorságát látom,
hogy mennyire tapasztalatlan, hanem a
potenciált benne, hogy mivé válhat egy
éven belül vagy két éven belül. És és ez
így érdekes módon ez folyamatosan így,
amikor éljük az életünket, ez így
működik, hogy az emberekre a potenciált
is rálátjuk. És talán azt látom a
nárcisztikus
személyeknél ez az egyik nagyz, hogy a
azt azt a változást, az azt a
potenciált, hogy mivé válhatna, azt el
kell engedjük. Ez már nem a mi útunk. És
és el elengedni azt,
hogy a legközelebbi családi eseményen is
jelenetet fog rendezni. Valószínűleg ez
nem fog változni, hogy nem fogok rá
tudni számítani. Lehet, hogy a jövővel
fog engem néha gázlángozni, megígér
dolgokat a jövőben, amit nem fog
megcselekedni. Ö. És akkor ha ezt a
radikális elfogadást be tudom ültetni az
életemben, talán ez vezet ahhoz a
védelemhez, ahhoz a hat árhoz, a a ami
ami árokhoz, ami ami megvéd minket
attól, hogy hogy
csalódjunk attól a mély fájdalomtól újra
és újra kitegyem magam annak a
csalódásnak.
Pontosan azt fogalmaztam meg, miközben
beszéltél, hogy életbátorságra van
szükség ahhoz, hogy meglássam, hogy itt
már az, amire az életutam
továbbfolytatásaként én nékem személy
szerint szükségem van, tehát egyfajta
dajkáló szeretettel odafordulni
önmagamhoz. Tehát ez egy életbátorság.
életbátorságot. Most itt összekapcsolnám
azzal is, hogy a bántalmazottak azért
tudnak sokáig benne maradni egy
kapcsolatban, mert hogy idealizálják azt
a kapcsolatot, tehát többet látnak bele
benne, mint amit eredetileg esetleg vagy
a későbbiekben akár pontosan, ami nem
volt. Tehát már eredetileg többet látnak
bele, és az eredeti belelátottságra
gyűrűződik föl az egész életút igazából.
Tehát arra építődik rá az egész életút,
és amit kiemelnék, még az is számít,
hogy könyörületes és irgalmas szívű
legyen önmagával szemben a bántalmazott,
hogy nem feltétlen eltékozolt évek, meg
elpocsékolt évek, és egy dajkáló
szeretettel ismétlen magam odaforduljon
önmagához, hogy tettem eddig, ahogy
tettem, de ezután valahogy mégis csak a
máskénteket ragadom meg, és ide ismét
behozom a logoterápia meg
egzisztenciaanalízisből a mégis
kulcszót. Tehát mégis van lehetőség
arra, hogy másként tegyem. Mégis
bizakodó vagyok, mégis ott a remény,
hogy fel tud fakadni az a az a fénysugár
az útamban, bármekkora is volt ez a
sötétség, és ugye megbocsájtani
önmagunknak, vagy önmagamnak, vagy
önmagának a személy, akárhogy is
ragozhatnám, hogy eddig benne voltam egy
könyörülettel, egy irgalommal, és akár
az is, hogy idealizáltam a kapcsolatot,
mert azért maradnak benne, mert ott van
az az idealizálás, hogy de megváltozik,
és újból adnak egy utat. Tehát itt a
szembenézés a teljes valósággal
van egy ilyen idézet, annyira tetszik,
nem tudom, hogy kitől van, de olyan
régen megszólított, hogy azokat a
személyeket, akiknél ott volt az a
tapasztalat, és most jön az idézet, hogy
akiknek a szemeit a könnyek átmosták,
azok már tisztában látnak. Tehát meg
vagyok győződve, hogy egy
bántalmazottnak a szemeit a könnyek, egy
túlélőnek a szemeit, a könnyek már
rengetegszer átmosták. És ők már egy
tisztább képet látnak, ők már egy
tisztább látással vannak benne azután a
következő életút folytatásban, miután
meghozzák ezt a radikális döntést, de
ugye ismét bejön a szabadakarat, amit
összekötünk egy reménnyel.
Igen, ez így elgondolkoztat engem, hogy
önmagában a könny az mennyire mos
tisztára, tehát tisztára moshat, mert a
fájdalom az felébreszt, de nem mindig.
Tehát azt látom, hogy a aki aki az
életét ciklikusan, újra és újra úgy éli,
hogy tegyük fel, külön válnak, megint
visszakerülnek, külön válnak, megint
visszakerülnek. Ez ez egy biológiai
függőség is amúgy, hogy
most megosztok egy személyes példát. A
feleségem
mondta, hogy szó szerint az édesapja
hangját hallotta a fülébe, miután még a
halála után is az édesapjának, hogy hogy
megszólalt, és ilyenkor a
a hangok minthogyha visszarántanának
minket abba, ahol voltunk előtte. Tehát
nem a tisztán látás volt feltétlenül,
amit kapott a sok könny által, hanem
hanem hanem egy küzdelem ott utána is.
Emlékszem, hogy ettünk salátát, így
étrendváltozást hoztunk be az életünkben
még jó pár évvel ezelőtt. Ez egy kicsit
olyan furcsa dolog, mert a székelyeknál
azért nem salátán
élnek. És amikor amikor salát ettünk,
akkor elkezdett így bégetni
a feleségem, és úgy elfogadtam, de
amikor már többször megismétlődött,
rájöttem, hogy erre rájöttünk közösen,
hogy ez egy minta. És kiderült, hogy az
édesapja volt az, aki mindig megpróbálta
megszégyeníteni így a környezetébe őt is
és a környezetét is, hogy hogy valójában
a a bárányok esznek salát, az igazi
székely az krumplit eszik és és nem
tudom, valamilyen húst.
És és annyira beleívódott ez, hogy már
önmagát szégyenítette meg vele azért,
mert mert mert ez egy ilyen pálovi
reflex, gyanítom, hogy hogy úgy
beleépült, hogy a salátával együtt a
bégetés is jár, és most már elkacagjuk
ezt, de ezt hány éven keresztül vitte
magába, és hány ehhez hasonló sérülést.
Úgyhogy önmagában a könny én azt látom,
hogy nem elegendő, de lehet, hogy
szükséges.
Hozzájárul egy tisztán látáshoz, de a
könnyben való megragadás, vagy a
könnyekben való megmaradás igazából ugye
egy életutat tudott lemetélni, vagy
megállítani egy életútnak a
kibontakozását. De én nagyon bizakodó
vagyok, és azt láttam, hogy a könnyek
után is van folytatás. könyvnek megvan
az a természetes adottsága, így vagyunk
alkotva, hogy ugye mikor elkezd valaki
sírni, akkor elkezd termelődni benne a
szerotonin hormon. Tehát az úgy átsegíti
nehéz időkön. Ott van az a belső
életszerűség, vagy ahogy alkotva
vagyunk, az életösztönnek az iránya, meg
az életösztönnek a feltörése nagyon erős
bennünk, hogy miket bírnak ki egyes
személyek. Tehát én csak így döbbenettel
hallgatok egy-egy utat végig, hogy
hogyan is bírta ki egyáltalán. És
szintén eszembe jutott egy ige, hogy
Istennek amúgy a terve az, hogy
végörömre derítsen bennünket. Tehát nem
a könnyáztatta napokban megmaradni, nem
a könnyáztatta időkben bel időkbe
beleragadni, hanem egy megsegítés, egy
továbbsegítés, egy átsegítés. És ahogy
írja az egyik zsoltár is, hogy átmenvén
a siralom völgyén forrássá teszi azt az
Isten. Tehát a könny valahol a siralom
völgye, a síralom völgye az a nehézség,
amikor valahogy azt látjuk, hogy csak
egy körbevettségünk van, egy
bezártságunk van, de azt mondja az
Isten, hogy forrássá fogom azt tenni
neked. Ott felfakad a völgyben a forrás.
És a könyvnek van egy ilyen funkciója,
hogy delegál egy nemesebb élet cél
irányába, elindít, tehát csak ad egy
tisztán
látást. Hoztam három
praktikus lehetőséget arra, hogy
megerősödjünk. Gondoltam, hogy ez kicsit
menjünk a praktikusabb irányba. Az első,
ami amit látok, az az, hogy ha már benne
vagyunk egy ilyen kapcsolatban, egy
párkapcsolatban, gyanítom, hogy sokszor
azon kapjuk magunkat, hogy nincs saját
hobbink, mert minden, ami ami az
életünkben volt, az átalakul és a
nárcisztikus fél köré épül. Ami neki
megfelel, amit helyesel, azt csináljuk.
És és a saját hangunkat elvesztettük.
És az egyik praktikus dolog az lehetne
szerintem, hogy kezdjen el valami
hobbit csinálni, bármi legyen az, vagy
valami olyan dolog, ami amiben
örömétleli egy kicsi sziget, amin meg
tud
pihenni. És persze úgy felkészülni erre,
hogy valószínűleg a párja kritizálni
fogja.
Mindenfélét érvet foko hozni, az egy mér
egy idő időpazarlás, vagy pénzpazarlás,
vagy értelmetlen dolog. Ennek
ellenére valami legyen egy legyen
valamilyen hobbija, egy kicsi hely, ahol
megpihenhet, legyen az festés, legyen az
tánc, legyen az csak egyszerűen sétakin
a parkba, de valami ami a
sajátja. Mit mit gondolsz erről? Én is
úgy gondolom, hogy az alkotás, mint
érték nagyon tovább tudja vinni az
egyént, és akárki tudja emelni őt abból
a beragadottságából, és közel tudja
hozni azt a kérdést, vagy annak a
kérdésnek az átengedését önmagán, hogy
mi az én
megszólítottságom, mert ki tudja, hogy
mikor időzött utajára azzal, mert az
életét igazából a mellette lévő mellé
összpontosította, vagy építette rá a
mellette lévőre. Tehát valahogy úgy
fogalmaznék, hogy ha mozdult az egyik, ő
mozdult vele, tehát ha mozdult a
mellette lévők, egy ilyen szimbiózisba
mozdultak együtt, és ez a
szétparcellázás, és akár be tudom ide
hozni azt is, amikor már megjelenik ez
az alkotás iránti vágy, vagy egy hobbiba
való gyökérverés, hogy megfigyeltem
ezeknél a személyeknél, akik egy mélyebb
ráismeréssel vannak már, hogy ők miben
is éltek ez idáig, hogy elkezdzenek
menni mélyen az önismeret meglelésének
az irányába.
És olyan érdekes, mert hogy az önismeret
úgy önmagába véve, mint olyan nagyon
szuper, de hogy egy picit bennébb
mennék, hogy az azt is jelenti, hogy a
megtanulása annak, hogy önmagunkkal
hogyan bánunk, tehát az önismeret
segítséget nyújt arra, hogy megtanuljuk
azt, hogy önmagunkkal hogyan bánunk. És
ahogy tanuljuk, hogy önmagunk hogyan,
egyre jobban rálátunk arra, hogy
másokkal hogyan bánunk, vagy hogyan
bántunk ez idáig. És ugye akár itt egy
picit beszélhetnék arról, hogy
mindannyian vagyunk időnként áldozzatok
és időnként bántalmazók is. Tehát védjük
a határainkat, csak nem mindegy, hogy
milyen jellegű bántalmazók, meg milyen
jellegű áldozatok vagyunk. Tehát azért
ott vannak azok az egészséges
védőfaktorok is. És ezt egy picit így
fontosnak is tartottam kiemelni. Akinél
hobbi van, az tud lenni egészséges módon
határvédő és egészséges módon
visszajelző az ő saját érzéseinek a
megfogalmazója. Tehát a hobbit úgy is
nevezném, hogy egy olyan kis parcella,
ami félretetik azért, vagy félretetett
azért, hogy ott önmagunk tudjunk
kibontakozni, önmagunk tudjunk mélyebben
beleérkezni, ott valami olyan, aminek
haszna van, az alkotás haszna, az
alkotásnak az öröme. És olyan érdekes,
mert Viktor Frank szintén visszatér ő
hozzá, mert hogy annyira megszólított ez
az egész
módszer, hogy ő az élményérték, a
beállítódási érték és az alkotói értéket
emeli ki, tehát mindig, ahol megjelenik
az, hogy ott már van egy szabadtérben
való mozgás, tehát az, hogy élményeket
gyűjtök, vagy az életre magára tekintek
rá, beállítódási értékem milyen, ahogyan
nézem, ahogyan szemlélem, hogy ugyanazt
látja-e egyik, mint amit lát át a másik
más nézőpontból merek szemlé elé. És az
alkotói érték ez az a akár a hobbik
működtetéséhez való megérkezés abban is
segít, hogy leveszem a szemüveget, amit
a mellettem lévő adott rám, és fölteszek
én egy másikat, és kiállok amellett,
hogy föltegyem a másikat, és elkezdek
kibontakozni mélyen önmagamban.
Igen. És talán még azt azt fűzném hozzá,
hogy lehet, hogy nem kapjuk meg elsőre
azt a hobbit, ami tényleg igazi alkotói
értékkel bír. Lehet ők is éreznünk kell.
Lehet, hogy hogy bolondok leszünk az
elején, bolondozunk, és mert mert sokan
felteszik magukbó a kérdést, hogy oké,
de fogalmam sincs, hogy minek fogjak
neki, és hogyha rosszul fogok neki,
egyből fog jönni a kritika, hogy hát
látod, nem csak, hogy értelmetlen, amit
csinálsz, hanem még rosszul is csinálod.
Én csak azt tudom mondani, hogy
mindenki, aki valami új dolognak fog
neki, először rosszul fogja csinálni.
Tehát ez garantált ez az egyik. A másik
pedig ne osszuk meg feltétlenül a
partnerünkkel. Tehát ezeket a kincseket,
ezeket nem kell egyből osszuk meg a a
akár a terapeutánkkal, vagy akár a
barátokkal, akik kör akik igazi barátok,
akik megértenek minket, velük
megoszhatjuk, de bizonyos dolgokat nem
tárunk, nem kell feltárni a partnerünk
mellett. Én is így gondolom. És olyan
érdekes, mert többször megfigyeltem,
hogy úgy fogalmaznak személyek, akik
felismerői voltak az addigi
helyzeteiknek, hogy na most már muszáj
nekem egy hobbim legyen. És nekem
annyira tetszik az, hogy a muszájban
benne van egy szabadság, tehát az még
elérhető. Muszáj egy hobbim legyen. És
az tetszik ebben a fajta szabadságban,
hogy igazából a szabadság az egy
felismert szükségszerűség. Tehát ha
muszáj hobim legyen, abban benne van egy
szabadság. A szabadságban benne van egy
felismert szükségszerűség. Hát nekem
szükségem van arra, hogy hobé van a
szabadságra arra, hogy legyen egy külön.
Pontosan az csak az én kis szigetem, az
csak az én kis valamim, amivel én
szöszölök, vagy olvasok, vagy bármi.
Olyan érdekes, hogy többen
megfogalmazzák, hogy az olvasmánynak az
íze, vagy az olvasmány értéke, hogy őket
mennyire ki tudja kapcsolni, vagy akár
egy kapcsolatnak az ápolása, ahol egy
kívülállóval rá tudnak nézni arra, hogy
nézd, én most itt vagyok, nézd, az én
életutam most itt van, itt reket meg,
itt állok, itt szeretném tovább
folytatni. Tehát igen, az egy kis
sziget, egy félretegettség. Igen, késs
hasonló most a második praktikus
megerősödésre térnék rá. Hasonló kis
sziget, egy gazdasági sziget. Sokszor
azt látom, hogy a
házastárs gazdasági függőségbe kerül,
mert a nárcisztikus fél lebeszéli arról,
hogy legyen saját munkahelye például,
vagy legyen saját félretett pénze, vagy
vagy saját élete. És bizonyos
szempontból ez a kiszolgáltatottságba,
ha belemegy egy fél, ez azt vehet észre,
hogy semmilyen nincs, és nincsen
semmilyen gazdasági szabadsága. Én én
ezt tudom javasolni, hogy kezdjen el
gondolkozni azon, hogy hogyan tud egy
bizonyos keretet akár félretenni, vagy
valamilyen valamilyen gazdaság minnek a
saját kontextusában ezt érteni fogja,
hogy ne legyen tökéletesen
kiszolgáltatva annak a a annak a nárci.
Most most nyilván párkapcsolatról
beszélünk, de lehet
szülőgyermekkapcsolatról is, ahol a a
szülő
tudatosan dependensé teszi a gyermeket.
Például láttam egy ilyen történetet,
ahol a szülő rábeszélte a gyermekét,
hogy egy drágább házat vásároljanak meg,
és a szülő az, aki fizeti a törlesztő
részletnek a nagy részét. Ez egy fajta
kontroll, amit a gyermek fölött fog
tudni tartani folyamatosan. Vagy azt
mondja a szülő, hogy gyertek,
költözzetek ide a házba, e ugyanis
emeletes házba lakunk, és nem kell
lakbért fizessetek valahol már min miért
fizetnétek máshol lakbért? És ez is egy
fajta kontroll. Tehát ezt látom így
praktikusan, hogy bármennyire is
kecsegtető a könnyebb utat választani.
Ilyenkor szembe kell nézzen a a az adott
fél, hogy hogyan lesz ő gazdaságilag
független, mert ha ha függővé válik,
akkor folyamatosan vissza fog élni a
nárcisztikus féle ezzel.
Igen. Érdekes, amit mondasz. Valahol,
amikor a függetlenné váló, vagy a
függetlenséget vágyó eljutra a pontra,
hogy neki van egy
értékcsomagja, ott kitul önegy észlelési
mező, hogy én erre szükség, hogy
odafókuszáljak mélyebben, és tényleg
félretegyek. És ilyen mondatokat
hallottam, amivel így rögtön kapcsolom
is azt, amit mondtál, hogy 20 évig nem
mentem dolgozni, mert arra kért, hogy
maradjak otthon, míg a gyerekek kicsik.
És én teljesen lemondtam a szakmámról,
és 20 év után odakerültem, hogy a
gyerekek kikerültek, és én egymagam
vagyok ott a hatalmas nagy házunkban,
amit ő épített, és mindenkinek úgy
mondja el, hogy nézd, ezt én építettem
és én valószínűleg az ő nevén is van.
Igen, az ő nevén is van. Valószínű nem
tudom, azt nem tudom, de hogy hallottam
ilyeneket is, hogy az ő nevén van,
többször fordult elő ez is. És olyan
érdekes ezt így látni, vagy akár azt is
hallani. Többször hallottam, hogy a
szülő szponzorizálja a gyermeket, de te
mondd el, hogy mit teszel azzal, amit
neked adtam. És ugye ezzel egy függő
odakapcsolódás. Odakötöm a gyermeket,
vagy odaköti a gyermeket ahhoz a
dinamikához, hogy segítelek, de az az
ára, hogy átlátható legyél, a számomra
totál transzparenciát kér. Tehát ugye a
szeretet, az adakozó szeretet, az
önzetlen, az nem azt kéri, hogy te aztán
számolja el, én adtam neked, de mutasd
meg, hogy mibe fektetted be. Az adakozó
szeretetbe ott van az a felelősség, hogy
én bizakodó vagyok, hogy jó az, amire te
elköltöd, és vagy te annyira bölcs, és
annyira értelmes, és annyira
felelősséghordozó, hogy jó helyre fog
kerülni mindaz, amit neked adtam. Tehát
itt a kötelékek, megkötöttségek vannak,
és nagyon intenzíven ugye itt akár már a
személynek a jogait is áttöri, merthogy
felnőtt gyerekekre meg felnőtt
emberekről van szó. Pontosan. Pontosan.
Jó, térjünk át a harmadik praktikus
tanácsról, amit hoztam, hogy vizsgáljuk
meg. Ez legyen egy munkahelyi
kontextusban. Azt javaslom, hogy kezdje
el készíteni a CV-t az a személy, aki
egyszerűen rájon arra, vagy a
munkatársa, vagy a fölöttese, vagy a
vezérigazgató egy nárcisztikus személy.
És ennek több praktikus oka van, hogy
érdemes a CV-t készíteni, mert a CV az
egy desilált változata a
kompetenciáinknak. Poroljuk le, milyen
kompetenciáink vannak, mert sokszor meg
se tudjuk fogalmazni, vagy a másik
személyben látjuk magunkat és
leértékeljük magunkat.
Úgyhogy készítsük el a CV-t, és ahhoz,
hogy egy jó CV-t készítsünk el, ahhoz
egy leltárt kell végeznünk, hogy hol
vannak a a hiányosságaink, hol vannak az
erősségeink, és a hiányosságainkon
elkezdünk tudni dolgozni, mert ez egy
felkészülési pillanat, és akár azt is
lehet, hogy egy-egy
interjúra elmegyünk egy másik céghez
titokba nyilván, de ez is hozzájárul
ahhoz, hogy egy önbecsülést
növeljen bennünk, egy rezilienciát,
amikor a másik személy
dependensé akar tenni minket, hogyha azt
mondja, hogy te úgyse kaptnál másik
helyen munkát, mert eddig is az én
kegyelmemből kaptál meg tehát
ilyesmiket, hogyha mondod, ez már
tudjuk, hogy nem igaz. Nem tudjuk, nem
igaz, mert akár egy egy-két helyre már
elmentünk és pozitív interjú, pozitív
visszajelzéseket
kaptunk. Ezzel kapcsolatban van-e valami
hozzáfűznivalód? Itt rögtön az a
kulcszól jut eszembe, hogy az
öndisztancia, tehát tudok-e távolságot
venni mindattól, amiben benne vagyok,
tegyük fel évek óta
alkalmazottként, amit érzékelek, tehát
talán a munkahelyről a legkönnyebb,
idézőelben a legkönnyebb kilépni, mert
ugye nincs ott az az érzelmi mély oda
kapcsolódás, ami egy családi köteléken
belül vagy kereten belül létrejön. Igen,
tapasztaltam hasonlót, és olyan érdekes
olyan mondatokat hallottam kiemelni,
hogy nem adnak át kellő
információt amiatt, hogy később belem
belém tudjanak kötni, hogy nem végeztem
el megfelelőképpen a feladatokat, tehát
hogy milyen dinamika tudja létrehozni,
azt odáig szeretnék elérni, hogy az
egyén azon gondolkodik, hogy beadja a a
felmondását és elkezd utánanézni egy
másik munkahelynek. Tehát rengetegszer
ezt a mondatot hallottam különböző
személyek ajkairól ismétlődni, hogy nem
adta át a teljes információt, csak
részlegest, és engem elszámoltatott
teljessel, és úgy fogalmazott, hogy de
én ezt neked már elmondtam. Tehát ugye
itt az átírások, az új narrációk, az ő
szerinte történő narrációk, a mellette
lévő szerint történő narrációk, és nem
tudja bevédeni magát az egyén, tehát egy
olyan kiszolgáltatott állapotba kerül.
Én többször ezt is így láttam, hogy egy
táborsyűl összes ugye ide hoztuk volt be
a repülő majmokat, hogy fel lesz
használva a főnök mellett lévő vagy a
nem tudom a kolléga mellett lévő pár
személy, aki nyitott arra, hogy akkor
dolgozzunk össze, mert hogy egységben az
erő, csak nem mindegy, hogy milyen
jellegű egységben milyen jellegű erő
bontakozik ki, mert amilyen az egység,
olyan erő fog kibontakozni belőle.
Igen. És egy toxikus egységnek az ereje
toxikus erőt hm tör be oda arra a
munkahelyre.
Nagyon jó, hogy hogy ennél a témánál
maradunk. És szerintem akkor most egy
kicsit váltsunk át a megerősödésről
konkrétan a az eszközökre, ami
amelyekkel meg tudjuk védeni magunkat.
És most visszatérve akkor erre
a munkahelyi környezetre én azt tudom
tanácsolni, hogyha valaki felismeri,
hogy a közvetlen fölöttese vagy a
munkatársa, vagy akár az alkalmazottja
nárcisztikus, akkor kezdjen el
dokumentálni, kezdjen el emaileket
elmenteni, egy egy dokumentumot
létrehozni, és biztonsági mentéseket
e biztonsági mentéseket elmenteni a az
emailjeiről, mindenféle olyan dokumentum
ól, amely bizonyíthatja az ő igazát. És
ezt konkrétan a feleségemtől tanultam,
kezdjen el naplót írni, egy ilyen
munkahelyi naplót, ahol dátumszerűen az
konkrétan megtörtént információ le van
írva. Pontosan ezért, amit mondtál, mert
utólag a múltat újraírja egy
nárcisztikus fél, és olyan módon állítja
be, ami nem igaz, vagy egy olyan
leegyszerűsítése lesz az információnak,
ami pontosan, hogy rossz fénybe tünteti
fel a az adott személy. De hogyha előre
fel vagyunk készülve, akkor ezt
csökkenti úgymond a nem mondom, hogy
megoldja, és nem mondom, hogy nyerhetünk
egy nárcisztikussal szemben, mert én nem
nem nagyon látom, hogy inkább egy olyan,
mint egy mocsárharc egy nárcisztikussal
szemben, hogy mind a ketten sárosak
lesznek. Nincs kiút, nincs ilyen királyi
út a nárcisztikustól el. M mindig mindig
veszítünk valószínűleg inkább csak
minimalizálni tudjuk a veszteségeket
azáltal, hogy dokumentálunk,
felkészülünk és és hogyha adott, hogy
hogyha szükséges, akkor akkor tudunk egy
összesítést adni, hogy ez történt
március 12-én ez a beszélgetés hangzott
el, és ezt az elmúlt hónapokban ezeket
írtam össze.
Igen, teljesen jó a meglátás,
nagyszerűnek látom a dokumentációt.
többen is mondják, hogy
le screenshotolják a üzeneteket, meg az
emaileket a biztonság megőrzése miatt,
vagy a biztonsági szféra kialakítása
miatt. és kiemelném azt, hogy igazából
akkor tud egy munkahelyen belül igazi
összedolgozás létrejönni, amikor
mindenki értéknek tekinti a másik
embert. És itt amikor eleve jelen van
egy értéktelenség, vagy értéktelen
megjegyzés, vagy akár ugye egy leuraló
magatartásmód, akkor az értékvesztettség
tör be abba a munkahelybe, arra a
munkahelyre. Tehát akkor tud létrejönni
egy
értékteremtő modell, vagy egy
összedolgozás megerősítése, hogyha
mindannyian értéknek tekintjük egymást.
És itt amit emeltél ugye, hogy a
nárcisztikus aspektusval felvenni a
harcot, hogy nyeressék. Tehát én azt
látom megfelelőnek, hogy elmozdulni
abból az irányból, hogy én vele nyer
viszon nyer nyerviszonba akarok lépni.
Tehát nem érdemes nem érdemes ezek üres
kartcsapkodások valahogy azt látom,
mintha a levegőbe csapkodnánk, és hogy
annak nincsen eredménye. Én inkább azt
látom megfelelőnek, hogy tényleg
dokumentációkat szerezni és
validálni újból megújból mindazt, amit
önmagunk átéltünk, és tényleg azzal,
hogy írásban adott volt, vagy hallotta
egy kollégám is, ő mellette esetleg vagy
az mellett kiállni, hogy ő mit hallott
meg ilyenek. Tehát konkrét
dokumentációk, inkább így fogalmaznék.
Igen, jónak látom és megfelelőnek, és
volt is ráett többször is. És talán amit
még praktikusan hozzátennék, hogy ne
séessünk. Igen, hogy az ilyen hirtelen
túlzott reakciók, amikor felismerünk
valakit, hogy te jó ég, most csapott be
ez a másik személy, most manipulált,
most akkor ne legyenek túlzott érzelmi
reakció lassítsuk le, aludjunk rá egyet,
dokumentáljuk nyilván, de még autoritási
pozícióból sem működik. Tehát ezt a
saját bőrömön tapasztaltam, hogy hogy
az, hogy odamegyek és konfrontálódok
vele, ez nem fogunk tudni nyerni.
Egyszerűen olyan narratívát fog
kialakítani rólunk, ahol mi leszünk a a
diktátorok, akik odamentünk, és ő az
áldozat, akitől akit mindenki amúgy
ösztönszerűen védeni fog. És konkrétan
tapasztaltam egy másik cég esetében,
hogy beszivárgott oda egy ilyen
nárcisztikus
személyiségű egyén, aki egy valószínűleg
egy toxikus, grandiózus nárcisztikus
volt, és a hónapok alatt lassan egy
ilyen egy ilyen kis gócot alakított ki a
cégen belül, ahol három-négy ember
folyamatosan úgymond a az udvart
tartásához tartozott, és kezdtek lázadni
a vezetőség ellen. És a sajnos a
végeredmény az lett, hogy az a
három-négy személyvel együtt ezzel a
nárcisztikus személyel aztán felmondott
és és ottgyta a céget, ami egy
hihetetlen válságot eredményezett, így
egy komoly szakadáshoz vezetett.
Úgyhogy én most is azt tanácsolnám annak
a vezetőnek, hogy ha teheti, ne vegyen
fel nárcisztikust. Úgy nyilván ez a
legbanálisabb, tehát hogy az, hogy
kompetens valaki, vagy kompetensnek
látszik, az nem elegendő ahhoz, hogy
valaki egy munkahelyhez tartozzon. Sokan
azt mondják, a kompetencia az az
egyedül, ami számít. Én most már úgy
vagyok vele, a kompetencia az
másodlagos, az elsődleges a jellem. De
ha már bekerült valaki, akkor kezdjük el
dokumentálni és lassan olyan helyzetbe
hozni, hogy hogy az a személy önként
akarjon felmondani. Tegyük fel,
elizoláljuk a munkába, olyan munkát
adunk neki, ami nem tetszik
neki. Hagyjuk, hogy ő legyen
túlzottan irritált és hangos, hogy
önmagát szégyenítse meg bizonyos
szempontból, mert hogyha mi belőlünk
hozza ki, akkor ezt egyből fel fogja
használni ellenünk. Úgyhogy én ezt tudom
tanácsolni azoknak a személyeknek, hogy
óvatosan
csigavér, a megoldás nem lesz azonnali,
úgy ahogy felvenni valakit is egy
próbaidőszakkal jár. Úgy is lehet, hogy
hogy akármilyen autoritással
rendelkezünk, többet ártunk a cégünknek,
hogyha ha frontálisan nekimegyünk annak
a személynek. Pontosan az fogalmazódott
meg bennem, ahogy beszéltél, hogy
először az észlelés jön létre, utána az
észlelésen túl szükséges, hogy a vezető
a szemlélésbe menjen bele, és utána,
ahogy már tényleg vannak valid többszöri
visszajelzések, szükséges valahol a
folyamatnak a konfrontatív részébe
óvatosan belelépdelni, de tényleg egy
várakozással, egy szemléllődéssel
előtte, mert én azt érzékelem, hogy az
az a vezető, aki megengedi az
etikátlanságot, és ugye be tud törni az
etikátlanság egy ilyen működésű
alkalmazton keresztül, tehát az a
vezető, aki megengedi az etikátlanságot,
előbb-utóbb káoszba megy az a rendszer,
amit ő vezet. Tehát egy krízis jön
létre, egy rendszerkrízis fog ott
létrejönni, de ugye ez tényleg szükséges
egy belső bölcsesség és egy felismerése
annak, hogy hol tudok józanul egy
döntést hozni és úgy konfrontálni, hogy
nehogy elvigye az egész ívét annak az
érték. És talán még ami eszembe jutott
az, hogy hívjunk egy másik személyt is
mindig a jó zan rálátót, egy külsős
rálátót. Egy nagyon jó példa jutott
eszembe erről. Tehát egyrészt ott van az
is, amikor amikor egy vezető az
autoritásával beszél egy alkalmazottal,
de akkor hívjon olyankor egy másik
vezetőt, egy egy középvezetőt, hogy két
személy legyen az, aki beszélget vele.
ami most így konkrétan eszembe jutott,
és a feleségem a lelkemre kötötte, hogy
ezt mondjam el, hogy ha nem vagyunk
autoritási
pozícióban,
és le kell üljünk beszélgetni ezzel a
vezetővel, akkor is hívjunk valakit
magunkkal ilyen-olyan indokkal
kapcsolatban, mindegy, hogy mi az, mert
egy nárcisztikus fél teljesen másképp
viselkedik, ha mást is látja, mintogyha
csak négy szemközle vagyunk. egy
szerepet akar felvenni, amiből nem tud
kimozdulni. És ezt konkrétan
tapasztaltuk a mi esetünkben, hogy hogy
amikor én is részt vettem azon a
beszélgetésen, teljesen más volt a
narratíva, teljesen más döntések
születtek és egy nagyon civilizált
beszélgetés volt. Utólag még azt is
mondhatta volna, minek kell ekkora
feneket keríteni neki? Hát milyen
civilizált volt. Persze én tudtam, hogy
miről van szó. Úgyhogy, úgyhogy amiatt
tudott a vérmérséklet, úgyhogy a
hőmérsékletlen maradni, mert ott voltam
én is, de tudom, hogy ha nem lettem
volna ott, akkor abban a pillanatban
máris fordul, és teljesen más arcát
mutatja az a nárcisztikus fél. Úgyhogy
ezt tudom tanácsolni praktikusan, hogy
vonjunk be. Minél több fény van, annál
inkább visszahúzódik egy nárcisztikus.
Minél kevesebb, minél a homályban, a
zavarosban tud inkább halászni egy
nárcisztikus személy. Igen. A sötétség
kedvez arra, hogy ő ki tudjon
bontakozni. ugye kedveli a káoszt, vagy
újra generálja, újrateremti a káoszt a
működése a az ilyen
személyeknek vagy embereknek. És az a
káosz valamelyest neki úgy tűnik, hogy
komfortos, mert történik valami
körülötte, de hogy szükség megvizsgálni
azt, hogy mennyire képezi ez az
életszerűséget, meg mennyire képezi az
életnek a lüktető irányát, az
életértékeknek az irányát. Úgyhogy egy
józanrálátás kívülről, egy segítő, egy
bárki bevonása kívülről biztos, hogy hoz
egyfajta higgadyságot, meg egy másik
fajta
perspektívamegnyitást. És amit érzékelek
és említetted, hogy a jellem alapján
kezdtél gondolkodni, hogy válaszd ki az
alkalmazottakat, vagy akár dolgozd
együtt azokkal a személyekkel. Olyan
érdekes, mert nyugaton ezt évekkel
ezelőtt, évtizedekkel ezelőtt
felismerték, és ugye az érzelmi
intelligenciát vizsgálják, és annak
alapján választják ki az
alkalmazottakat. És valahol hallottam
azt a megfogalmazást is, hogy ugye
betanítható az egyén, meg tudja tanulni
azt, ami a lexikális tudás rá tud látni,
de hogy az érzelmi intelligencia azért a
jellemnek egy olyan működésével kapcsol
össze, vagy egy olyan stabil jellemet,
egy jellen formálást tud létrehozni, ami
megállja a helyét úgymond, és hogy a
viharokban is állóképes marad.
Gyökereket ereszt. Igen. Gyökereket
ereszt, és nem csak egy felszínt látunk
abban. Most így ahogy beszélgetünk, még
egy praktikus dolog eszembe jutott. Most
ugye azért is veszem előre a munkahelyi
körülményeket, mert azok talán
egyszerűbbek a ahogy mondtad, nem
annyira
nem annyira alkotják az életünknek a a
fundamentumát, habár nagyon fontos, mert
a munkahelyünkön töltjük el az ére
töltött időnk jó részét, vagy ha nem a
nagyobbik részét.
Ha van egy olyan helyzet, hogy egy
nárcisztikus személy hozott egy döntést,
és egyszerűen képtelen abból a döntésből
kimozdulni, mert ő már kimondta, mert
ilyenkor mi történik? A döntéssel együtt
az ő jellemét is úgymond kockára teszi,
azt mondja, hogy ha ez a döntés, ha ha
beismerem, hogy helytelen volt ez a
döntés, akkor beismerem azt, hogy
tévedtem. Márpedig egy nárcisztikus fél
nem téved, mert amit kimondott, azt mint
egy félisten 100%-ig kimondta, és az úgy
van. Na most mit lehet ezzel kezdeni?
pláne, hogyha nem vagyunk hatalmi
pozícióba, nincs autoritásunk fölött az
adott személy fölött, tegyük fel a a
főnökünkről, vagy a közvetlen
fölöttesünkről van szó. Az egyik dolog,
amire rájöttem, az az, hogy ennek a
személynek azt kell üzenni, hogy ez,
amit mondunk, ez egy
kivétel. Figyelj, amit mondasz, az
tényleg úgy van általában de ez most
kivétel. Amiatt kivétel is mondasz
valamit intellektuálisan, hogy amiatt
kivétel, mert most éppen ilyen
helyzetben van a cég vagy a piac, most
nem tudom. És ezzel két dolgot érünk el.
Az első dolog, hogy az a másik személy
nem kell
változzon. Elismerjük, hogy általában
igazad van, de de ez most egy amúgy is
egy másik eset, de amúgy nem kell
változ. És ez a másik személy
megnyugszik, hogy jó, rendben, akkor én
nem kell változzak. A másik dolog, ami
ilyenkor történik, az az, hogy
felajánljuk neki a lehetőséget, hogy
mint
intellektuálisan okos ember, ilyenkor a
büszkeségére hatunk, il mint
intellektuálisan okos, értelmes valaki,
hát csak látja, csak beismeri, hogy hogy
ez ez egy kivétel és akkor egyszerre meg
is lapogatja a vállát, hogy nem kell
változzak, és fel is ismertem ezt a
helyzetet. És ez nagyon fontos, ez egy
olyan trükknek tűnik úgymond, amit lehet
alkalmazni.
De ez nagyon fontos, hogy néha vannak
olyan helyzetek, amikor egyszerűen nincs
kiút. Vagy lesz egy megoldás, vagy nem
lesz egy megoldás. És
én ezt tapasztaltam amúgy a saját
bőrömön, hogy ennyire arogánsak ezek a
nárcisztikus személyek, ennyire nem
veszik észre magukat, hogy ennyire
képtelenek arra, hogy beismerjék, hogy
tévedtek. Tehát ez az egyik. A másik
pedig az, hogy engem is meglep, de nem
lehet eleget dicsérni egy nárcisztikust.
Tehát már én érzem magam furcsán, hogy
hogy elmondom neki és pozitív
visszajelzést adok, de ő úgy mintogy
mintogyha a levegő lenne, ez teljesen
magától értetődőnek veszi, hogy ezeket
kapja. Úgyhogy bizonyos
szempontból lehet dicsérni bőven a
nárcisztikusokat.
Még akkor is, hogyha ha tegyük fel
ellenérzés van bennünk, ami ami tényleg
jól csinál, azt nyugodtan kiemelhetjük,
sőt nem is árt, hogyha kiemeljük. Nem
kell ilyen szempontból a haragunkat
tartsuk folyamatosan. Nyilván
jegyzetelhetjük azokat a dolgokat, amik
megvédenek minket, de nyugodtan
dicsérhetjük azt a nárcisztikus felett,
mert a nárcisztikus személy az ebből
táplálkozik. És
és ezt tudom praktikusan tanácsolni,
hogy ha tényleg nincs kiút, akkor
mondjuk azt, hogy ez legyen egy
kivétel. És a másik pedig az, hogy
emeljük ki a pozitív oldalait. Annak a
ha nem akarunk meghasonlni önmagunkkal,
akkor az igazi pozitív oldalait emeljük
ki. Úgyhogy de emeljük ki, és és nem
lesz fonák a a nárcisztikus fél számára.
teljesen természetesnek fogja venni,
hogy ez történik. Igen. Munkahelyen ez
tud működni valóban. És itt
szétválasztanám, hogy tényközlők tudunk
lenni a munkahelyen. Tehát tud működni
azért radikálisan, hogy csak tényeket
közlök és tényekre jelzek vissza. Érzi
azt a biztonságot, hogy néki nem szükség
változnia. De hogyha lényközlő leszek,
lényeg lényegi elemekre török, vagy
mélyen a lényegre török, ugye ott már
azt érzi, hogy valami nem jó, és neki
szükség változnia. nem változik, és
aroganciával lép föl, tehát az még
jobban bevon egy ilyen negatív
spiráleffektusba. Tehát a tényekről
beszélni lehet, és ez tud adni egy
védelmet. Még az is megfogalmazódott
bennem, ahogy beszéltél, hogy ugye a
munkahely is fontos, persze egyértelmű,
tehát
létfenntartásként ott van, de nem
életfenntartásként. Tehát amikor valaki
párkapcsolatban, szülőgyerek
kapcsolatban, ott az életfenntartás maga
az, ami veszélyeztetve van. De amikor a
létfenntartás, tehát a létezésemért, a
fizikai, materiális javaknak a
megszerzéséért van valaki ott egy
munkahelyen, tegyük föl. Tehát ez lehet
egy átmenet, átmenetileg kibírom, mert
szükségem van arra, hogy de tényleg
könnyebb kivonódni egy munkahelyi
környezetből, merthogy nem az élet
mélysége, nem az életlét értelme, az
életmély értelme, nem a lényközlés az,
ami engem oda vissza tud vinni, hanem
az, hogy eltávolodom és megyek egy másik
irányba, és próbálkozó leszek egy másik
irányba. Tehát nem az a kötelék, sokkal
kevésbé másabb a kötelék, tehát nem az a
köteléknek a súlya, a kötelék egy picit
jobban oltható, jobban enyhíthető.
Pontosan. És nem is hiába ezzel kezdtük
ezt a beszélgetést, mert ezek könnyebb,
de akkor akkor menjünk bele a a nehéz
részbe. Mit kezdjen valaki? Hogyan tudja
megvédeni magát valaki, aki egy ilyen
házastársi kapcsolatban van? Én egy pár
szakaszt neveztem meg. Egy nagyon jó
ötletet kaptam egy bizonyos könyvből.
Most így hirtelen gondolkozom, hogy a
könyvnek a szerzője kicsoda? Talán
Suzann Thomas, nem tudom, talán nem
vagyok biztos benne, de gyógyulás a
rejtett bántalmazásból az a könyvnek a
címe, és nemrég találkoztam ezzel a
könyvvel, és nagyon tetszik, ahogy ő
szétszakaszolja, és egy picit arra
próbáltam így apelálni, hogy nézzük meg
együtt ezeket a szakaszolásokat. Ő
bántalmazott volt, nagyon mélyen
bántalmazott a az édesanyja által, és le
is írja ezt nagyon mélyen a könyvében,
hogy ő miket tapasztalt meg, hogyan élte
meg, hogy hogyan vált szabaddá, és ő
első szakaszként a kétségbeesés
szakaszát
emeli ki. Tehát igazából amiről ez idáig
beszéltünk, egy picit valahol vissza fog
mutatni több minden, ami így a
szakaszokban most meg fog jelenni. Tehát
szükséges egy érzelmi káosznak valahol
felszínre törnie, egy félelmi faktornak
megjelennie, hogy hát meddig működik ez
így, hogyan tudok tovább menni. Tehát
ugye ez a belső energiafeltörés, ha ez
nincsen, ha nem fáj eléggé, nincs
változás. Tehát amíg nem fáj eléggé a
vajudás, addig nincsen életszületés,
hogyha a szülésről beszélek, és kicsit
tudok itt egy pár huzamot hozni. Tehát
igazából tehát a kétségbe belesés
szakasza, az elindulásnak a a fázisa, az
elindulásnak a szakasza, minden
kétségbeesésnél ott van egy kételkedés
is, mertogy ugye ott van benne az
egyénben, hogy hát akkor képes leszek-e
arra, hogy irányt vegyek föl. Tehát nem
gond, ha így kezdődik. Sőt, az a jó,
hogy a kétségbeesésemben valahol a
siralom völgyében leszek kiáltó,
felkiáltó, és ez a felkiáltó szó fog
átvinni abba az irányba, ahol elkezdünk
az ismeretek begyűjtése felé, a
forrásorientáció felé mozdulni. Ugye
erről is egy picit beszéltünk, amit ott
kiemelnék, és itt ugye egy pár kulcszót
már át is beszéltünk, hogy mi jellemzi a
narcisztikus aspektussággal bírókat, a
akár a ködösítés, a rágalomhadhagyjárat.
akár ugye az idealizálás, a lebecsülés,
a szerelmi háromszögelés meg minden is.
Tehát ezeket a kulcszavakat, ahogy
elkezdik az egyének megérteni, hogy
egyre inkább kapnak egy tisztább képet,
és egyre jobban ez az öndisztancia,
távolságteremtettség elkezd kialakulni
náluk. Tehát kívülről kezdik el tudni
jobban szemlélni az egész történést. És
amit még kiemelnék, hogy a harmadik
szakasnál azt emeli ki, hogy a
felébredésnek, a ráébredésnek a
szakasza. Tehát ez egy kicsit ilyen aha
élmény, akár így is nevezhetném
használván ezt a pszichológiai
kifejezést, hogy értem. Igen, most már
értem. És ott elkezd a harag felszínre
törni. Tehát ott már nem az van, hogy
megrekesztem, meg belrekesztem magamat
egy haragba, hanem elkezd felszínre
törni. Aha. Tehát ez idáig ez történt.
Most már értem. És olyan érdekes, hogy
alkotva vagyunk, mert hogy ebből is erőt
tudunk nyerni, hogy most már értem a
kétségvesésből ugyanúgy erőt tudunk
nyerni, azaz eddig és ne tovább. Utána
ugye, ahogy említettem, az ismeretek
begyűjtése abból is hát húy kitul a tér,
tehát más a a az észlelési perspektíva,
van ott valami, tehát kinyílnak a
receptorok, beveszünk más adást,
elkezdünk feltérképezni másmilyen
mezőkből információkat, és ugye ez a
felébredés, vagy a ráébredésnek az
időszaka. Tehát miben voltam altatva?
Miben aléltam el ez idáig? Akár ugye
mint a Csipke Rózsika állam, hogy 100
évig elalis megy a herceg, hogy a
bozótokon keresztül mse meg a hercegnő.
Tehát egy utat jártam be, bozótos az út,
de hogy az elalélás is ott volt az
utamban. És annyira tetszik nekem ez a
külön probléma megfogalmazása az a fél
megoldás már. Pontosan pontosan. És itt
tudják a ráébredés szakaszáb külön
köszi, hogy ezt mondod, megfogalmazni
azt, hogy mit éltem át, hogyan működött
eddig és mit éltem át. Tehát itt már
konkrétumok hangzanak el. És amit
érzékelek ebben a szakaszban, a
felébredés, ráébredés időszakában, hogy
már nem szégyennel beszélnek arról, hogy
én nem itt tettem, és hogy nem voltam
eléggé kitartó, meg hogy vagy eléggé
kitartó voltam, de hogy milyen kitartást
hoztam létre, vagy akár olyan is van,
hogy biztos én nem tettem valamit jól.
És érdekes módon ezt többször hallom,
hogy biztos én nem tettem valamit jól,
mert nem változott a mellettem lévő.
Tehát az
önáztáztatás többször felfakad. Sokkal
többször látom ezt felfakadni. Akkor
ahogy azt átvesszük, hogy de ő mégis mit
tett? Hogyan viszonyult az értékeivel
ehhez a kapcsolathoz? Hogyan tudott hű
maradni ehhez a kapcsolathoz? És ugye
itt a párkapcsolatokról beszélünk még
mindig, tehát ez óriási, de akár ezeket
a szakaszolásokat behozhatjuk szülő,
gyerek és más milyen kapcsolódásokra is,
akár baráti kapcsolatok, munkahelyi
kapcsolatok ugyanúgy érvényes rám. Igen,
ez így van. Tehát akkor az aha pillanat
után feljön a harag bennünk, a
megfogalmazása a dolgoknak, a
realitáshoz vissza csatolódás, amikor
megfogalmazzuk, hogy mi történt
konkrétan, és hogy én mit tettem ebbe
ebbe bele, és a másik személy mit tett
ebbe. Mi a következő lépés? A következő
mit gondolsz,
mi ezek után micsoda? Hát gondolom
valamilyen stratégiáknak a a
kidolgozása. Az elhatárolódás és a
határok. Ugye ez a legjobb stratégia.
Tehát nagyon jól mondod, ez a legjobb
stratégia. Tehát az, hogy tudjam, hogy
meddig tart a másik, meddig tartok én,
hol kezdődöm én, hol kezdődik a másik.
Tehát kábé az egyik tanárom úgy
fogalmazott, hogy ameddig a másik óra
tart, ott van a mi határunk. Tehát nem
mehetek azon belül. És ugye ez egy
tiszteletbeli kérdés is, hogy egy
megfelelő érzelmi távolságra, de vannak
helyzetek, amikor megfelelő és
szükséges, hogy fizikai távolság is
kialakuljon. Tehát érzelmi távolság
mindenképp. Ugye ott különemeltük a
szülő gyerekkapcsolatokat akár vagy a
szülőpárság kapcsolatot, azt aztán
végképp, de hogy szükség van egy érzelmi
távolságra. És igazából az is a
határkérdésekhez tartozik, hogy
konstatálni azt a valóságot, hogy ez,
hogy határok vannak. Nagyon sokan
megijednek attól, hogy ez a kapcsolat
végét jelenti. Tehát azért nem mernek
határokat a bántalmazottak felépíteni,
felállítani, mert ez akkor a kapcsolat
végét jelenti. És ha a végét jelenti,
még nincsenek kész arra akár, hogy
esetleg vége legyen, vagy van olyan is,
hogy nem lesz vége, mert hogy van olyan
is, hogy nem lesz vége, akkor vajon
elveszítem-e őt, ha vannak határaim? De
ugye a határok az elsősorban arról szól,
hogy mi hol vagyunk, meddig vagyunk
elérhetőek. Tehát egy öntiszteletről is
szól a határ, egy önbecsülésről is szól
a határ. Egy választóvonal ad egy biztos
keretet. Én eddig tartok, én itt
végződök, én itt érzem biztonságban
magam. Jogom van, pontosan jogom van
határt húzni. Jogom van arra, hogy
kiálljak azért, hogy van nekem egy
vonal, ami jelzi, hogy eddig és ne
tovább. És akkor ilyen szempontból
becsatolódik az, amit praktikusan már
mondtunk eddig, hogy legyenek
hobbijaink, legyen egy saját anyagi
keretünk, legyen egy CV-nk, amit
előkészítünk. Tehát ide csatolódnak be a
határokhoz, hogy hogy stratégiákat
építünk ki, hogyan növekedjen az a kicsi
mag bennünk, ami amit felismertünk, az a
képesség arra, hogy ne legyünk
áldozatok, képesség arra, hogy
proaktívan cselekedjünk a világban. És
ez egy kis valami, egy mustármag, ami
elkezd növekedni. elkezd növekedni és
reményt ad, és lépésről lépésre nem
sietve ezt elkezdjük növelni és
kapcsolatokat kialakítani, szövetségeket
kialakítani, akár egy terapeutával,
barátokkal megkapni. És talán fontos itt
megemlíteni azt, hogy ugy ahogy a
terapeuták nem értik ezt, hogy mi ez.
Környezetünk tele lesz olyan
személyekkel, akik ugyanúgy nem értik.
Tehát ez az aha pillanat nem történt meg
nekik. Egyszerűen én azt javaslom, ne
osszuk meg, ne beszéljünk a mi
szenvedéseinkről. Ha elkaptuk az első
pillanatban, hogy a másik személy
empatikus a a nárcisztikus ragadozóval
szemben, de hát milyen gyerekkora volt,
nézd meg. Azért mégse olyan rossz, mint
ahogy leírod. Nem lehet címkézni az
embereket. Nézd meg, hogy ennyi ennyi
mindent megtesz a családotokért. Ét
nappátével dolgozik, és azért, hogy te
ne kelljen dolgozni, és akkor te ilyen
hálátlan vagy. Szóval amikor a legkisebb
rész is ilyen szempontból elér hozzánk,
tudjuk, hogy az be kell meg kell húzzuk
a hat árkot azzal az azzal a másik
személlyel szemben is.
Pontosan. Pontosan. és azt is valahogy
belekalkulálni, amit érzékelek. És
többször ismétlődő folyamat volt, hogy
azzal, hogy határt húzok, az egy picit
azt is jelenti, hogy a másik személyhez,
ami hozzátartozik, a vele való kedves és
kellemes életesemények átélésének az
elengedése vagy az újradefiniálása is
odatartozik a határkérdéshez.
Tehát egy védelem védelem adott ponton
pontosan gyász is. És hogy nem tudom és
nagyon jó, hogy mondott külön köszi ezt
a gyászót, merthogy valahol a
határkiépítés egy gyászfolyamatot is
jelent, merthogy az addig működőt, az
addig beváltnak tűnőt engedi el az
egyén. És érdekes, hogy a határkérdések
után ez a szakember a az ötödik
szakasznak a helyreállítást hozza be.
Tehát a határkérdések, a határok
kialakítása után tud a helyreállítás
létrejönni. És ugy pontosan a
helyreállítás szakasza. És ott annak már
a fő témája a remény és a megújulás,
hogy kezdjek el abba járni, amit
kiépítettem, a remény és a megújulás. És
megannyiszor megláttam, meg úgy
megfigyeltem is, vagy át is beszéltem
különböző egyénekkel, akik érintettek
voltak, hogy az új és az ismeretlentől
való félelem időnként megint oktatja a
lábukat, és vannak hatáscsálások, hogy
egy alkalommal vagy x időn keresztül
sikerült valamit kialakítani,
fenntartani, de vannak csúszkálások, és
ide megint behozom azt, hogy tudok-e
eléggé irgalmas lenni önmagamhoz,
önmagunkhoz, tudunk-e eléggé kegyelmesek
lenni önmagunkhoz, hogy tévedők leszünk.
Tehát adott ponton a csuszkálás is
valahol lehet, hogy belefér, mert hogy
valami újat tanulunk, egy távolságot
venni tanulnunk attól, ami eddig
működőképesnek bizonyult, vagy
működőképesnek tűnt. És ugye ilyenkor a
segítő beszélgetéseknek a fő feladata,
hogy támogatni az újban való
megerősödésbe, merni támogatni, merni
lépdelni előre. De nézd, mi történt
azóta, mióta ez így kialakult, milyen
átélések voltak, hogyan volt előtte.
Nagyon szeretek a meglévőségekre
fókuszálni. Mi az a meglévő, amivel
gazdálkodhatsz? Az elért eredményekre,
az elért megragadásokra fókuszálni, az
elért reményteli kis mezőkre fókuszálni.
Mit ragadtál meg eddig belőle? Mi tud
ott a tied lenni? Ott annak milyen ízze
volt? úgy külön szoktam venni, hogy van
az életnek íze, de van az életnek szaga
is. Tehát nem mindegy, hogy valami
életszagú vagy életízű. Tehát az az
igazság, hogy a bántalmazó
kapcsolódásokban való lét azért egy
kemény izadságszagot generál az emberbe,
egy életszagot, de hogy ugye tisztában
is látja utána az életet, és ide egy
nagy zárójelt megejtek, és mindjárt egy
picit akár az életzhez is visszatérek.
Olyan érdekes, ahogy alkotva vagyunk.
Nekem az alkotás csodája meg az arra
való ránézés, hogy hogyan működik az
életszakaszunk, az életunk a különböző
életszakaszokkal. Úgy vagyunk alkotva,
például egy párkapcsolatba, amikor lépik
bele valaki, ugye 20-as éveinkbe, jobb
esetben, ahogy lépik bele valaki, ott
még ez a nagy megvalósítás és a
bizonygatás ezzel az erővel lépik bele,
hogy de én aztán jó és akkor megváltozik
s megváltoztatom s változunk s nem tudom
bármi, ott van ez a nagy erőfitoktatás.
Tehát ugye hajlunk abba az irányba, hogy
valami nagy történjen. Utána mikor lesz
egy másfajta megérkezés, oda már a
bölcsesség maga térbe. Tehát ez a nagy
megvalósítás után jön a bölcsesség
szakasza, és utána a bölcsesség szakasza
után az elcsendesedés időszaka. És azt
figyeltem meg, hogy a bántalmazó
kapcsolatokba működők, a bántalmazottak
a bölcsesség szakaszába kerülnek bele,
amikor egy távolságot tudnak venni
attól, vagy egy feltérképezésre jutnak
rá, vagy egy felismerésre, hogy hú, én
most mibe is érkeztem vele. És olyan
gyönyörű, hogy a bölcsesség szakasza az
tele van tűzdel különböző kihívásokkal,
mert az eddig járatlant kezdem másmilyen
módon tanulni meg, járhatóvá tenni a
pusztámat, felfakasztani a vizet a
pusztaságban, a gödrökbe valahol
meglátni, hogy egyenes utak hogyan
tudnának létrejönni. Tehát ott a
bölcsesség szakasza intenzíven meg tud
jelenni. És ugye ott van a kegyelem is.
Tehát van, amit mi emberi erőből
képtelenek vagyunk elvégezni. Sőt azt
mondom, hogy nagyon képtelenek vagyunk
elvégezni, de hogy ott az Istennek a
kegyelme, hogy tovább hisz és adja azt a
kellőbölcsességet, hogy a gödrökön, a
sáncokon túl tudjunk lépni. És utána,
amint már említettem, a csendnek az
időszaka, az elcsendesedés időszaka
jelenik meg, hogy már nem akarunk
akkorát bizonyítani, már nem akarunk
annyira úgy ott lenni, ahogy eddig
áldozat üzemmódban, úgymond, hanem
akarunk a csendben szemlélődök lenni,
hogy de eddig amiben benne voltam,
szoktak úgy fogalmazni, tényleg
belegondoltam, s amíg benne voltam, nem
is gondoltam arra, hogy hát csoda, hogy
túléltem. olyan gyönyörű mondatok. Nekem
ebbe gyönyörködik a lelkem, hogy hogy
csoda, hogy túléltem, hogy tudok-e
ránézni az életemre úgy, hogy csoda.
Tehát önmagába véve a túlélés is tud
csoda lenni a túlélésnek a csodája. És
egy picit ide visszahozom ugye az
életszag meg az élet ízét. Tehát az
életnek van ízze és valahol az ízt pont
ezt tudja létrehozni, hogy hát egy
csoda, ami velem történt. Hát én túlélő
vagyok. És ugye gyönyörű felismerni azt,
hogy ebben van egy önbecsülés, hogy
amikor rájövök arra, hogy sokkal erősebb
vagyok, mint amilyenek gondoltam magam.
Pontosan pontosan. És úgy fogalmaznék,
hogy a méltóságnak a köntösét kezdi el
ott hordozni az ember. És annyira
tetszik nekem az az
ige, úgy hangzik, hogy a gyásznak a
ruhája helyett a dicsőségnek a ruháját.
Most nem idézem szó szerint az igét, de
hogy ez az Istennek a terve, hogy ham
helyett fejdízt adjon a gyászolóknak.
Tehát hamú helyet fejdész, merthogy ez a
működés, ez a fajta kapcsolati működés,
amit átélnek a bántalmazottak, ez egy
hamú, tehát egy szégyenteli működés
adott ponton, tehát beleég az ő
személyiségükbe. És hogy újra definiálni
önmagukat abba az irányba, hogy de a
hamu helyett kaphatok én fejdzt, mert az
Istennek ott a kegyelme, az Istennek ott
a szeretete, ami fel tud emelni, amit
tovább tud vinni. És ugye nagyon jó a
tudományos megközelítés is, és én mindig
odateszem ezt, hogy de egy picit nézzük
meg más irányból is. És ugye ez a
transzcendens irány, tehát az imanens a
transzcendensel, amikor találkozik a
földi lét, a felső léttel. Tehát hiszem,
hogy ennek akkora nagy
továbblépési folyamata tud lenni ilyen
módon, hogy belekapaszkodok valami
olyanba, egy olyan ígéretbe, ami egy
valódi ígéret, ami egy konstans,
állandóan ott lévő ígéret.
Itt itt ami ezek nagyon szép dolgok,
amiket mondtál. És egyet is értek, hogy
ez ez egy amikor kijön ebből valaki,
akkor egy
megerősödött, sokkal nagyobb öntudattal
rendelkező személy jön
ki. Viszont picit mintogyha, ahogy
beszéltél róla, mintogyha ebbe az el van
egy eltávolodás, amikor van terünk arra,
hogy elcsendesedjünk.
És ez egy tényleg egy ideális egy egy
filmbeillő pillanat, amikor a a főhős
minden viszonttagság ellenére a végén
egy egy belső nyugalommal, részben
gyásszal és részben
elfogadással tekint a múltjára. De mi a
helyzet azokkal a kapcsolatokkal, ahol a
házasság még mindig nem akar elválni?
Ennyi időt eltöltöttünk együtt, egy 60
nmes lakásban lakunk. Igazából nincs
nagyon hova elmenjek. A gyerekek már
kirepültek. Nyilván, hogy tudok saját
saját kicsi szigeteket alkotni, mert
most már tegyük fel, itt vagyunk,
kirepültek a gyerekek, megtehetem azt,
hogy hogy ilyen-olyan dolgokat
megcsináljak, nyilván úgy, de
folyamatosan jön az a toxikus hatás, a
lebecsülés, tehát hogy valójában nincs
akkora nagy terem, hogy eltávolodjak
attól a másik személytől. olyan,
mintogyha minden nap egy kicsit
mérgezett vizet innék, és muszáj abba a
levegőbe, abba az atmoszférába részt
vegyek, hogy milyen praktikus tanácsot
tudnánk adni azoknak a személyeknek,
akik ezt a fajta eltávolodást nem tudják
megtenni. Ez szembe jut szintén Viktor
Franknek egy mondata, hogy mindenkinek
megvan a saját ausvicca. Tehát lehet,
hogy őkik tényleg ez a saját ausviccuk,
hogy nem tudják megtenni azt az
eltávolodást.
Ott szintén ebbe kapaszkodnék bele, hogy
a körülmények ellenére hol vannak a
mégiseim. És ugye ide behoznám azt a két
kulcszót, vagy eléggé ismerős
fogalom. A szürke szikra technika meg a
sárga szikratechnika. Tehát ezeket
mindenképp emelném. Tehát itt a
tényközlés ugye, tehát szürkévé válok a
másik személy számára. Nem les
analmassá, szürkévé, nem leszek annyira
megtámadható, hogyha ezt így
próbálometni, milyen a szürke szikről
kommunikációban. Tényekről beszél,
röviden, tömörmondatokba, tőmondatokba
beszél. Igen, nem lehet, hogy csak egy
emojsival reagál egy üzenetre, egy oké,
vettem az adást egy lájkkal, hogy vettem
az adást. nem megy bele érzelmi
beszélgetésekbe. Tehát emlékszem, nemrég
valaki átküldött egy kis üzenet
másolatot és nagyon mély érzelmi
megnyilvánulása volt az egyénnek, aki
írta az üzenetet annak, aki megmutatta
nekem, és kérdezte, hogy mi a
véleményem, hogy én erre hogyan
reagáljak. És elmondtam, hogy két út
van. egyik az, hogy érzelmileg
kapcsolódsz az ő reakciójához, ami egy
ilyen önigazult
üzenetről tanúskodott, meg hogy ős, ő
jól csinált mindent, meg hogy ez a
grandiózitás, meg hogy minden ott volt
benne. És mondtam, hogy van az az út,
amikor érzelmileg reagálsz és megértően
reagálsz, de akkor ő tovább fog téged
provokálni. Dönthetsz, hogy
perszegván így van, pontosan. Vagy lehet
a másik oldalt, hogy csak tényeket. Oké,
köszönöm a visszajelzésedet, értettem.
És képzeld, hogy másnap kapok kapok egy
másik üzenetet ugyanattól a személytől,
és azt mondja, képzeld el, a B opciót
választottam, és mondom, na is, és csak
egy lájkot tett, tehát nem tudta bevonni
őt. Nem volt, nem volt partner. És erre
figyelni úgy, ahogy te mondod, és nagyon
jó, amit mondasz, hogy ha van kampa,
ahova bekapcsolódjon, és adunk neki
teret, be fog kapcsolódni. Tehát
megtanulni, akkor együtt élni azzal, ami
van, ami adatott, mert hogyha nincs más
választás, és tényleg van úgy, hogy
gazdasági függőség van, és tényleg az
egyén ki van arra szolgáltatva. Tehát ez
nem olyan könnyű. És ugye eszembe
jutott, ahogy mondtad, hogy a meséknél a
boldog végkifejlett, de amíg a boldog
végkifejlett létrejön, ott rengeteg
küzdelem van. Ott óriások vannak, ott
ücskök vannak, ott sáskák, ott
sárkányok, ott egy csomó küzdelem van,
amin végigmegy az egyén. Te hogy tud
boldog végkifejlett lenni én bennem
egyénként önálló módon önbecsüléssel
felvértezve, kellő önbecsüléssel
felvértezve, hogyha ott van a mellettem
lévő szobáb tegyük föl valaki olyan,
akinek ez a működése. Tehát csak így
ugye ez a szürke sziklachnika, amit már
említettem, hogy távolságot úgy venni,
hogy unalmas leszek számára tényközlő.
Ezt még említettük a beszélgetés közben.
És a sárga sziklachnika, hogyha arról
van szó, akkor egy kis érzelmi részt be
lehet villantani, ide számolni a
következményeivel. Tehát hogyha a
gyerekekről van szó, szükséges, hogy
megértem, hogy te így érzel, oké, én ezt
elfogadom későbbiekben, majd még
beszélhetünk róla, de itt most egy
direkt valamiről szeretnék veled
beszélni, hogy a gyermekünknek az
egyetemi ottlétét szükséges fizetni,
hogyan tudjuk megoldani. Tehát a tényeg,
visszaigazolni akár, hogy oké, hogy így
érzel, de mélyebb érzelem működtetésben
nem belemenni. Akkor gyakorlatilag a
környezetünkért csináljuk a sárga
sziklátem nem a magát pontosan akkor
négy szem köz vagyunk visszaérhetünk a
szürkére pontosan visszatérni igen
pontosan most hirtelen az jutott eszembe
hogy lehet hogy a chat gpt is tud
segíteni nekünk ebben, hogy elmondjuk
hogy szeretnék választ adni erre az
üzenetre de szürke szikla technikával mi
legyen a válaszunk és akkor csak GPT
visszahívja válaszold azt hogy oké
rendben. Biztos, hogy tudsz segíteni?
biztos, hogy igen. A ugye én nékem
viszont emberszerű meg emberillatú meg
életi ízű az, amikor ember az emberrel
beszél, de tud segíteni. Tehát készény,
hogy mankó tud lenni adott ponton,
amikor valaki beszorul. És mondom, hogy
akkora nagy többlet volt ennek az
egyénnek, és hogy én akkor most erre mit
válaszoljak, és hogy a két út ott van
mindig valahogy. És amit még kiemelnék,
ez a hölgy emeli ki szintén is az utolsó
szakaszként a hetedik szakaszt, amit
említ, hogy járni és fenntartani az új
életformát. Ízlelgetni, ugye ide már
behoztam, hogy az élet íze, tehát
ízlelgetni azt, amiben vagyok, és ide
tud bejönni az, hogy hobbi, elkezdek
alkotni, elkezd futni az egyén, vagy
bármit, amit addig nem művelt, vagy
kapcsolódni. Olyan érdekes, nemrég
valaki úgy fogalmazott, hogy elnézést
kérek tőled, hogy nem voltam mindenkor
olyan kollaboratív, de olyan szenvedő
voltam. És mondom, hogy hát én úgy
érzékelem, hogy megértem a szenvedő
fájdalmát. És azt mondta az
illetőválaszként, hogy de én csak arra
összpontosítottam, hogy milyen terveket
dolgozza ki a jövőre nézve. És akkor
egyszer csak jön, hogy mennyi mindent ő
kidolgozott, és abban elkezdett járni,
és örömmel és csillogó szemekkel
mesélte, hogy ő miben jár, és hogy
kapcsolatokat épít újra épít, átépít,
átalakít. És itt kifejezném, vagy
kiemelném a minőségi kapcsolatok ottlét,
tehát nem mennyiségi kapcsolatokkal
szükséges tele szórnunk az
életszféránkat. Legyen az az 1 k legyen
az ott, de hogy több ne, de annak legyen
egy minőségi vetőlete. Ez is egy
opció. Én ezt még órákig tudnám
folytatni. Az az igazság, hogy van is
egy pár jegyzetem, amit amivel
legszívesebben belemennék. Viszont
álljunk itt meg. Egy egy nagyon szuper
beszélgetés volt. Nem tudom, te hogy
érezted most magad így másodszorra?
Szabadban éreztem, mint először. És így
voltam végig valamelyes benne izgalommal
is, merthogy érdekes így beszélni. És
valahogy azt is érzem, hogy ami történik
egy-egy beszélgetésen, egy egyéni
beszélgetésen, ugye mégsem az, ami
történik itt a kamerák előtt, de hogy
aránylag egy békességgel voltam benne,
meg egy belső szabadsággal, tehát nem
azzal a súllyal jött, de hogy tényleg
szeretném azt, hogy az ember mellett
állni, és hogy megláttatni, hogy az
embernek hatalmas az értéke, és bárhol
tartanak. Tehát a hamu helyett fejdz tud
adatni, és a gyászruha helyett tud egy
tündöklő, egy ünneplő ruha adatni. És ez
nem azt jelenti, hogy elbagetalizáljuk,
vagy nem vesszük észre, hogy van
szenvedés, van, de hogy holleljük meg
azokat a szabad parcellákat, ahol tovább
lehet menni, a leválasztódást.
Igen. Például én most a kétharmadát
tudtam nagyjából átbeszélni azoknak a
dolgoknak, amit készítettem. Ö de ez egy
nagyon jó alkalom arra, hogy bevonjuk a
a nézőközönséget is, hogy gyertek és
írjátok meg kommentbe, hogy milyen más
praktikus dolgot tapasztaltatok az
életetekben, amivel meg tudtok erősödni,
és amivel amivel konkrét eszközként meg
tudjátok védeni magatokat.
Én én itt azt látom, hogy bizonyos
szempontból van egy bizonyos
tapasztalati hátterünk, bizonyos
dolgokat megtapasztaltunk mi is, de
sokkal tágabb az, amit ez a pár ezer
vagy pár tember igazából most olyan
25000 ember nézte elejétől végéig a mi
podcastünket. Ki tudja talán ezzel az
epizódal is ez lesz. És gyertek,
kezdjétek el megosztani ezeket a
tapasztalatokat, hogy mindannyian
tanuljunk belőle. Én Én nagyon kíváncsi
vagyok, hogy miket fogtok majd írni.
És el tudom képzelni, hogyha a kommentek
alapján még igény lesz rá, akkor fél év
múlva még egyszer leüljünk és
beszélgessünk arról, amiről amiről még
nem tudtunk beszélgetni. Nagyon köszönöm
szépen, hogy itt voltál velünk. És
én én az az igazság felszabadultam egy
kicsit, tehát hogy nehéz volt ezelőtt
egy fél évben nagyon sötét volt, és
utána egy napig éreztem egy ilyen
depresszív nyomást magamon, hogy ez
azért kemény volt, nem felkészületlenül
ért, de most most úgy érzem, hogy
folytatódhat a napunk tovább. Én is ezt
érzem. A témának súlya van, de hogy ami
itt történt, az egy gondol
gondolatébresztés és egy felszólítás
arra is, hogy a belső párbeszéd, a belső
dialógus milyen önmagunkkal szemben,
milyen másokkal szemben és ugye
akármilyen az Istennel való
kapcsolatunkban, merthogy ez tud hozni
egy erőt és köszönöm az itt lléted.
Köszönöm szépen, hogy itt voltál. Szia!
Szia! Szia! Ha tetszett ez a műsor,
akkor iratkozz fel kérlek a
csatornánkra. Ezzel tudsz támogatni
minket. Köszönjük a Week kávé
közösségnek a jó kávéért, az ötvös
udvarnak a helyért, valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért.
Nélkületek nem jöhetett volna ez létre.